BILLS ON THE AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB FOR SIXTY THREE AN ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB SEVEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES HAVE
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
WE HAVE EIGHT ITEMS ON CONSENT
TODAY WE'LL BE LIMITING
TESTIMONY TO TWO PEOPLE PER SIDE
WITH TWO MINUTES PER PERSON.
ALL OTHER WITNESSES PLEASE STATE
ONLY YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION NO OTHER TESTIMONY WILL
BE ALLOWED.
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET SO
WE'RE GOING TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DO HAVE AN
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU FOR HUSTLIN
RIGHT OVER WE APPRECIATE THAT.
COME RIGHT UP I THINK YOU HAVE
ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AB THIRTY NINE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATOR [inaudible]
SENATORS YES.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO ASSEMBLY
BILL.
THIRTY NINE A BILL THAT --
PROPOSES SAY.
BIPARTISAN ROAD MAP TO GET
CALIFORNIA BACK TO WHERE WE USED
TO BE.
AMONG THE TOP TEN IN THE NATION.
N. K. TWELVE PER PEOPLE SPENDING.
I'D LIKE TO START WITH THE
SIMPLE QUESTION.
WHY IS CALIFORNIA THE WORLD'S
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY FORTY
FOURTH IN THE NATION IN PER
PEOPLE SPENDING?
WE NEED TO DO BETTER THAN THAT.
THIS BILL PROPOSES A ROAD MAP A
PLAN ON HOW TO PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR ALL
SCHOOL KIDS IN CALIFORNIA.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE.
THE FIRST POINT I'D LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS NOT A NEW
IDEA.
WHEN WE ADOPTED THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA IN?
TWENTY THIRTEEN SOME OF US WERE
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE -- WHEN
WE ADOPTED DEL CFF?
WE ALSO ADOPTED THE FUNDING
TARGETS TO GET CALIFORNIA BACK
TO WHERE WE USED TO BE BEFORE
THE BUDGET CUTS THE LEGISLATURE
HAD TO MAKE.
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
GOVERNOR BROWN PUSHED FOR THESE
FUNDING TARGETS AND THESE
FUNDING TARGETS PROVIDED A ROAD
MAP OR BENCHMARKS BY WHICH WE
MEASURE OUR PROGRESS TOWARD
ACHIEVING THESE GOALS.
THANKS TO THE STRONG ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IN THE LAST SEVEN YEARS
WE'VE RESTORED THIRTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE MET THE
FUNDING TARGETS.
SO NOW WE ARE PROPOSING L. C. F.
F. TWO POINT NO.
NOW THAT WE'VE MET OUR FIRST
ROUND OF FUNDING TARGETS TO
RESTORE EDUCATION FUNDING CUTS
MADE DURING THE RECESSION.
WE NEED TO SET A NEW GOAL BUT-NEW FUNNY TARGETS TO GET
CALIFORNIA.
AGAIN BACK TO WHERE WE USED TO
BE IN THE TOP TEN IN THE NATION
IN PER PUPIL SPENDING.
WE DID THIS BEFORE WE CAN DO IT
AGAIN.
I'D LIKE TO NOW TURN OVER -- AND
ASK -- THE FOLSOM CORDOVA
UNIFIED SUPERINTENDENT SERRA
COLLISION.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
VERY GOOD TO ME AT TWO PEOPLE
TWO MINUTES EACH SOLELY DECIDE
WHO THE OTHER PERSON IS PLEASE
PROCEED.
ERICA WEEKEND TO FRIEND TENET
FULSOME CORDOVA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT JUST EAST OF HERE.
WE CALL ON THE LEGISLATURE TO
ESTABLISH NEWS LCF TARGETS VIA
A. B. THIRTY NINE AFTER THE
CURRENT LCF AT FUNDING TARGETS
ARE FULLY FUNDED THIS YEAR.
WE SUPPORT GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
AND THE LEGISLATURE'S DEDICATION
TO CONTINUALLY TO CONTINUE TO
FULLY FUND THE LC FF IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY CFF TARGETS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN OUR REACH THIS YEAR
THERE IS NO PLAN FOR HOW PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING INCREASES
WILL BE ALLOCATED TO SCHOOLS.
ADDITIONALLY THE FORMULA WOULD
ONLY PROVIDE ANNUAL COST OF
LIVING INCREASES WHICH WILL COME
CLOSE TO MEETING THE NEW AND
GROWING MUST FIND COSTS.
RELATED TO OUR PURRS AND STIRS
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS.
WHICH CONTINUE TO INCREASE ADAM
IN ADDITION TO OUR MANDATED
SPECIAL ED COSTS IN FOLSOM
CORDOVA THAT THREE POINT 26%
COLA -- DOES NOT COVER THE COST
OF OUR ON GOING AHEAD.
STEPPING COLUMN COSTS OF ABOUT
2% OUR ON GOING STIRS AND PURRS
CONTRIBUTION OF ABOUT 3%.
AND OUR INCREASES IN SPECIAL ED
FUNDING OF OVER 12% FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
AB THIRTY NINE WOULD PROVIDE A
ROADMAP TO INCREASE THE LC FF
BASED GRANTS AND ALSO ENSURES
FUNDING INCREASES TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL IN CONCENTRATION
GRANTS CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
LAW.
WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO DISTRICTS
SUCH AS MINE WHO HAVE LARGE
POPULATIONS OF POOR AND ENGLISH
LEARNERS.
AB THIRTY NINE KEEPS THE
EXISTING LCF A FUNDING.
FORMULA INTACT AND THERE ARE NO
CHANGES SUGGESTED TO THE
DEFINITIONS OF AND DUPLICATED
STUDENTS OR COMPONENTS OF THE
FRONT FUNDING FORMULA.
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO ESTABLISH NEW
TARGETS AND A PHASED IN TIMELINE.
ESTABLISHING THESE NEW TARGETS
DOES NOT PRECLUDE THE
LEGISLATURE FROM ADDRESSING
OTHER EDUCATIONAL ISSUES BUT IT
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN THE CORE
ENGINE UP EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR FOLSOM
CORDOVA SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
INTERVENTIONS FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS ARE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND ARE AT RISK STUDENTS.
MENTAL HEALTH AND COUNSELING
SERVICES AND SMALLER CLASS SIZES
FOR MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOLS AND
SCHOOLS WITH OUR ENGLISH
LEARNERS.
ALL DISTRICTS WOULD BENEFIT FROM
INCREASED INVESTMENTS TO PUBLIC
EDUCATION TO IMPLEMENT
STRATEGIES TO ENHANCE STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT AND TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GET YOUR
NEXT WITNESS WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
LEYVA I HEAR LEYVA HERE WILK
PRESIDENT WILL CARE CHIANG.
CHAIN HERE THE RUSSELL RUSSELL
HERE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
THANK YOU X. WITNESS PLEASE
PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN LEYVA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE
NEED TO AVERAGE KID I'M IN
EDUCATION ADVOCATE. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
REPRESENTING MORE THAN THREE
QUARTERS OF A MILLION MEMBERS.
THE FF IT WITH SAID THAT UPON
FULL IMPLEMENTATION THE FORMULA
WOULD GET CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
BACK. TO WHERE THEY WERE IN THE
200-072-0008 ADJUSTED INFLATION.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE GREAT
RECESSION THIS WAS A NOBLE GOAL.
HOWEVER NOW THATWE HAVE REACHED
ITS INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION WE
NEED AN ELF FF THAT GETS
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS TO WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE.
COMPETITIVE WITH THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
THE HARD TO THE L. CFF CHALLENGE
IS THE INADEQUACY OF THE BASE
FUNDING.
LEVELS OF ALFIE FF IF THE ALTHEA
F. TARGETS CANNOT PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY FOR A GREAT
EDUCATION FOR OUR CHILDREN.
THAN THE NOTION OF EXTRA MONEY
FOR SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION IS A JOKE.
AS ONE FEEL CFF BASES IN
ADEQUATE SCHOOLS RECEIVING THOSE
DOLLARS WILL ALWAYS BE TORTURING
THE RULES OF THE EXTRA FUNDS IN
ORDER TO MEET THE OBJECTIVES.
OF THE BASIC SERVICES.
IF WE WANT SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION GRANTS TO TRULY
LIVE THE EDUCATION EXPERIENCES
OF OUR KIDS AND POVERTY ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND FOSTER
CHILDREN.
THE BASE CANNOT BE UNDER FUND.
WE CAN AND SHOULD FUND BOTH BY
ESTABLISHING CONTINUED TARGETS
FOR LC I FELT FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS.
REMEMBER.
HELLO IN CONCENTRATION GRANTS
DON'T WORK IF THE BASIS IN
ADEQUATELY FUNDED.
WITHIN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PRIORITIZING LC FF MAKES A
STEADY BUT IMPORTANT DIFFERENCE.
WITHOUT NEW TARGET TO BOO SELFIE
FF BEYOND JUST COLLATE CANNOT
MEET A POTENTIAL FOR BEING AN
EFFECTIVE AND FAIR FORMULA FOR
THE DISTRIBUTION OF APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES FOR EVERY CHILD.
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM PARENTS
AND TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS?
IS THAT BY NOT HAVING AN
ADEQUATE BASE FUNDING STUDENTS
ARE LOSING OUT IN SOME OF THE
FOLLOWING.
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL CURRICULUM AND
SUPPORTS WHICH COULD BE IN THE
FORM OF COUNSELORS SOCIAL
WORKERS AN OUTSIDE SERVICE
PROVIDERS CREDENTIAL P. E.
TEACHERS FOR K. THROUGH.
TWELVE MUSIC DANCE THEATER AND
ARTS IN K. THROUGH TWELVE I CAN
ASK YOU TO WRAP UP YOUR TIME
LIMIT OKAY IT'S ONE THING.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY CLASS SIZES.
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE FOR STUDENTS
TO HAVE CLASSES OF THIRTY TO
FOUR THIRTY TO FORTY OKAY SO I
LEAVE YOU WITH TWO THUGHTS IF I
COULD -- THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
ADVOCACY AND FUNDING IT IS
IMPORTANT TO INCREASE THE
FUNDING FOR BASIC EDUCATION.
CALIFORNIA K. TWELVE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS TO NO LESS THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL WILL HELP STRAIGHT FROM THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO THE
FUNDING.
UNDER L. CFL AND TWO LCF ELF IS
A MECHANISM WE USED TO DECIDE
HOW MUCH DISCRETIONARY MONEY ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS RECEIVE FROM
THE STATE.
IT IS A WAY WE DECIDE HOW WE
SLICE OF THE PIE IT DOES NOT
MAKE THE PIE BIGGER.
SOUL PLEASE INCREASE OUR PORTION
OF THE PIE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
DID YOU WANT TO STATE YOUR NAME
AND SUPPORT.
I AM A C<c.cyan> IT COULD BE A</c>
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK
YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- LISKI AND WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES WE WITHDREW OUR
OPPOSITION AND ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AS AMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AND STAFF MUCH THOUGHT ABOUT IT
ON BEHALF DOES STILL ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS.
AXLE SUPPORTER AND A CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
IN THE GARAGE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
DOMINIC TOMARI -- HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RON ROUTE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT AND ALSO A CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NICK
WRONGLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY PERFECT.
ASIAN THE SAN BERNADINO COUNTY
DISTRICT ADVOCATES FOR BETTER
SCHOOLS THE PALACE VERDES
PENINSULA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTRY COSTA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
ALL IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING RACHEL CIRCLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ASK ERA CAN AVAIL
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE SAN YSIDRO
SCHOOL DISTRICT SCHOOL EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA.
AND THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING ANDREA
BALL ON THE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION AND THE OWNER ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORNING MICHELLE MCGANN WOULD ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
FUNDING COALITION THE SCHOOLS
FOR SOUND FINANCE AND CLOVIS AND
TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
HELLO MELANIE I CANNOT ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT FRESNO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AN AVID IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JEFF BACA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF TWENTY THREE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SUPERINTENDENTS OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
J'AI SUPPRESS IT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATTHEW KOGAN TWENTY YEAR
TEACHER FROM LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THIRTY SILVA FROM SAITEK A
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL RE
ENGAGING OPPORTUNITIES IN
SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ASK OF ALL OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
SURELY DOWN BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION CO SPONSOR.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERG WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I ASKED WE
AYE VOTE THANK YOU DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
MOVED WITH THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR WILK MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM THREE AB THIRTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WELL.
CAME CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN.
THANK YOU BILLS ALPHA WE WILL
LEAVE THE WILL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT I SEE THAT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA SORRY. TO ME LIVE
OFF THE LAST PART IN NAME.
COME ON DOWN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
GOOD MORNING PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SENATORS -- I AM HERE TO
PRESENT AB.
THREE FIVE FOUR AS A FORMER
TEACHER OF THIRTY YEARS IN
ACTUALLY CURRENTLY ON A LEAVE OF
ABSENCE I KNOW HOW VITAL IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR OUR STUDENTS TO
HAVE A PROPER NUTRITION.
IN ORDER TO REACH THEIR FULL
ACADEMIC POTENTIALS I'M GONNA
TAKE A MOMENT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE HERE JUST TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT -- OVER THE THIRTY
YEARS I TAUGHT IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS -- THERE'S A RAY OF TYPE
OF LUNCH IS THAT WHETHER THE
STUDENTS BRING THEIR OWN LINES
OR BY LUNCH.
AND SO FORTH.
BUT AS THE YEARS PROGRESSED FROM
MY EARLY YEARS OF BEING ABOUT
TWENTY ONE AND STARTING TO TEACH
TO MUCH OLDER.
REALIZE YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE --
PERFORMANCE IS BASED MANY MANY
TIMES ON HOW WELL OUR STUDENTS
ARE DOING NOT ONLY EMOTIONALLY
BUT ALSO IF THEY ARE HUNGRY
THERE CERTAINLY ARE NOT GOING TO
DO AS WELL SO IN A SIMPLE.
WAY THIS BILL SAYS THAT ALL K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS SHOULD PROVIDE AT
LEAST ONE NUTRITIONALLY ADEQUATE
SCHOOL MEAL A DAY TO ALL
STUDENTS ELIGIBLE FOR FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEALS.
NOW SOME SCHOOLS ACTUALLY DO
THAT IN MANY DO AND SOME NOT
ONLY DO ONE A MALE BUT THEY
ACTUALLY DO A BREAKFAST MAIL AS
WELL WE CAN GO ON TO ANOTHER
PIECE OF LEGISLATION ABOUT THE
NUTRITION FACTOR BUT FOR NOW
WE'LL FOCUS ON THE MILLS.
BUT THERE ARE SOME SCHOOLS WHO
MAYBE HAVE A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF WHAT WE'D CALL
TITLE ONE STUDENTS OR THAT FIT
THE FREE AND REDUCED AND MANY
TIMES THEY DON'T GIVE THAT MAIL
TO THOSE STUDENTS EVEN IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
SO BUT THIS WOULD REQUIRE ALL
SCHOOLS TO AGAIN PROVIDE -- THAT
MALE TYPICALLY IT'S THE LUNCH
TIME.
MALE AND IT DOES INCLUDECHARTER
SCHOOLS I DO WANNA -- MAKE A
COMMENT ON THAT WE WANT TO
STUDENTS NO MATTER WHAT SCHOOL
THEY'RE GOING. TO TO MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE THE ONE MALE AGAIN IT
MAY BE A VERY SMALL PERCENT DOES.
TO HAVE A A KITCHEN DOES NOT
MEAN THEY NEED TO HAVE A QUICK
MEANT BUT AS WE KNOW THERE'S
WAYS.
TO MAKE SURE STUDENTS HAVE SOME
THAT I CANNOT TELL YOU AND
FULLER TEN WHICH IS CONSIDERED.
A FAIRLY HIGH AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT -- AND YET WE DO HAVE
MANY TITLE ONE SCHOOLS BUT AT
WHAT WE CALL OUR HIGHER END --
SOCIAL ECONOMICALLY I WOULD
OFTEN HAVE STUDENTS COME AND ASK
ME FOR A GRANOLA BAR OR WHATEVER
IT WAS BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY
HADN'T EATEN.
SO -- THAT IS WITH THIS BET BILL
IS ABOUT IN WITH ME I HAVE SETH
BRAMBLE WITH THE CAL CTA AND RON
ARE WRAPPED CALIFORNIA CFT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PLEASE PROCEED
THE MORNING OF SEPTEMBER HERE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE FIVE FOUR MEMBERS LAST
YEAR WE PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE WITH THE
HELP OF OUR AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AND PARTNERS LIKE
THE PTA CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY
ALLIANCE AND WESTERN CENTER.
ON LAW AND POVERTY -- THAT BILL
ENSURE THAT CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO AT LEAST
ONE FREE OR REDUCED PRICE MEALS
EACH DAY THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION BELIEVES THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO PARTICIPATE IN
NUTRITION SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAMS
MUST BE UNIFORM.
BRAVO AND ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
INCLUDING CHARTER SCHOOLS EVERY
DAY THAT SCHOOL IS IN SESSION.
BECAUSE POVERTY NEGATIVELY
IMPACT THE CHILD'S ABILITY TO
LEARN AND DEPRIVE THEM OF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY GROUPS
SHOULD WORK COOPERATIVELY TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF IMPOVERISHED
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WE DO SUPPORT
FOOD AND FAIRNESS. FOR ALL
CHILDREN ALL STUDENTS DESERVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO THE BASIC
RESOURCES THAT SUPPORT THEIR
SUCCESS INCLUDING SCHOOL MEALS.
RESEARCH AND COMMON SENSE TELL
US THE CHILDREN MUST BE WELL
NOURISHED IN ORDER TO LEARN GROW
AND ACHIEVE IT THERE.
THIS BILL.
BUILDS ON WHAT WE CODIFIED LAST
YEAR AND I WOULD NOTE IT WAS
BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR FOR
THAT BILL RECOGNIZING ONE SIMPLE
FACT HUNGRY STUDENTS STRUGGLE TO
LEARN.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY IS A
SIMPLE TRANSPARENCY BILL IF A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR CHARTER
SCHOOL OR COUNTY OFFICE OF
EUCATION IS NOT PARTICIPATING.
IN FEDERAL MIL REIMBURSEMENT
PROGRAMS WE WANT TO PUT SOME
SUNSHINE ON WHAT ALTERNATIVE
MEAL PROGRAMS ARE BEING ADOPTED
AS THE ASSEMBLY ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT 8% OF OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND 74% OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
ARE NOT PARTICIPATING IN THE
NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM OR
THE SCHOOL BREAKFAST PROGRAM WE
KNOW WE HAVE A MANDATE TO
PROVIDE AT LEAST ONE FREE OR
REDUCED PRICE MEALS.
OUR DAY TO ELIGIBLE PUPILS BUT
AS A STATE WE HAVEN'T TAEN ANY
MEASURES TO MONITOR ALTERNATIVE
PROGRAMS AND ENSURE ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS AT ALL CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE NOT GOING
HUNGRY.
NO STUDENT SHOULD GO HUNGRY IN A
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL SCHOOL
MEALS ARE A CRITICAL RESOURCE
FOR ALL STUDENTS IN NEED NO
MATTER WHICH PUBLIC SCHOOL THEY
ATTEND.
WE DO WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND WE ARE JUST
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE FIVE FOUR THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS GOOD MORNING RON ROUTE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE FIVE FOUR I'D LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE --
WE KNOW THAT HUNGRY STUDENTS
CANNOT LEARN TO THEIR POTENTIAL
THE FEDERAL -- SCHOOL BREAKFAST
AND LUNCH PROGRAMS PROVIDE
NUTRITIOUS MEALS TO LOW INCOME
STUDENTS IT'S CRITICAL THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE FED PROPERLY.
AND THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
THOSE SCHOOLS THAT OPT OUT OF
THE PROGRAM ARE STILL PROVIDING
NUTRITIOUS MEALS TO THE STUDENTS
WHO DESERVE THEM.
AND FOR THAT REASON WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S LORETTA ARENAS
FOURTEEN YEAR TEACHER I SUPPORT
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BY BURNELL DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SIGNAL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
SORRY COME RIGHT ON UP.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
HELLO HOW ARE THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT CENTER THE
MAJORITY OF OUR SMALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY
INVOLVED IN THE NATIONAL SCHOOL
LUNCH PROGRAM.
ACTUALLY PROVIDE MEALS AND THE
REASON THEY'RE NOT INVOLVED IN
THE PROGRAM IS BECAUSE OF THE
PAPERWORK.
SO IT'S COUNTER INTUITIVE TO
REQUIRE PAPERWORK FOR THE
PROGRAM THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
PROVIDING.
I'M IT ACTUALLY STUDIES ACTUALLY
SHOW THAT REDUCING PAPERWORK
ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE MORE
MEALS FOR HUNGRY CHILDREN.
THE SECOND CONCERN WE HAVE WITH
THE BILL -- IS THAT.
THE NEW REQUIREMENT THAT YOU
PROVIDE SPACE FOR FOR EATING
THESE MEALS AS MOST OF YOU KNOW --
PROP THIRTY NINE THE VOTER
APPROVED INITIATIVE.
THAT REQUIRES SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
PROVIDE SPACE FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS AT THIS POINT IN TIME
DOESN'T EVEN PROVIDE CLASSROOM
SPACE FOR MOST OF OUR CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
SO THE IDEA THAT WE'RE NOW
ASKING DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE
LUNCH ROOM SPACES WELL IS A
CONCERN SO THAT THEIR CONCERNS
OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM BACK THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS DOCTOR PAN.
THANK YOU IN THE SUMMER QUIRK
SILVA THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD WHY APPRECIATE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION I THINK AS YOU
POINTED OUT AND SO IS A
PEDIATRICIAN I KNOW -- GOOD
NUTRITION IS VERY IMPORTANT
THERE ARE NATIONAL STANDARDS I'M
SURE THEY'RE HELD.
I APPRECIATE THE CHALLENGE ON
THE SPACE BUT YOU NEED A PLACE
TO EAT THE MEAL I MEAN I THINK
ALL OF US WHO WORK HERE WHO
SOMETIMES SELL SKIP LUNCH AND SO
FORTH -- RECOGNIZE THAT THAT'S
NOT REALLY THE BEST CIRCUMSTANCE
INSTANTLY FOR STUDENTS THEY NEED
TO HAVE -- SAFE APPROPRIATE
PLACES BOTH EATEN BE SURE THEY
HAVE APPROPRIATE MEALS AND THEIR
NEEDS SO WHILE FISHY TO ME
SCHOOLS MAY PROVIDE MEALS WE
NEED BE SURE OF THE PROBATE
STANDARD AS WELL SO -- SO I'D BE
HAPPY WITH THE BILL APPROPRIATE
TIME.
THANK YOU SIR PAN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I'M SORRY SENATE -- US SOME
LIMóN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AT JUST THAT THAT I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT BUT ALSO NOTING
THAT -- AS FAR AS SPACE FOR
LUNCHES IN PRIVATE SETTINGS -- I
VISITED SCHOOLS IN JAPAN AND
THEY REGULARLY HAVE THEIR SCHOOL
MILLS ACT OTHER DESK WITH THEIR
TEACHER -- AND IT'S A VERY
FAMILY ORIENTED ORIENTED TYPE OF
EXPERIENCE SO THERE'S LOTS OF
THAT OUT IN AS FAR AS PAPERWORK
WE ARE IN EDUCATION ARE TO LOTS
OF PAPERWORK IT'S JUST ANOTHER
PIECE OF PAPERWORK AND NOT THAT
WE DON'T ACCOUNT FOR MINUTES BUT
WE HAVE LOTS OF PAPERWORK AND I
GUESS.
WE COULD START TAKING THAT OFF
BY CHANGING THAT BUT FOR THIS
BILL.
I APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SALLY WOMAN -- WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR PAN MA'AM
SACRIFICE CALL THE ROLL ITEM FOR
AB THREE FIVE FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
I WILL.
WILK AYE CHIANG CHIANG I'D
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER REQUIRE PAN
PAN HI.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH FOOD TO GET
OUT BUT WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU YOU MEMBERS.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU IS
HERE PLEASE COME ON UP
[inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
YEAH.
YES PLEASE YOU MAY SAID IF YOU
PREFER BUT WE HAVE A NICE PODIUM
FOR YOU.
I PREFER TO STAND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PERFECT FOR SEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I'M HERE
TO THE PRESENT AB.
EIGHT A ILL THAT AIM TO PLACE
ONE ARE MORE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
ALL K. TO TWELVE SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
THAT ESTABLISH A RACIAL OF
REQUIREMENT OF ONE MENTAL HEALTH.
PROFESSIONALS PER EVERY SIX
HUNDRED STUDENTS WHILE GIVING
SMALLER SCHOOL THE FLEXIBILITY
TO FULFILL THIS REQUIREMENT.
AB A REQUIRED COUNTIES TO DIRECT
ONGOING PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE ACT FUNDING. TO SCHOOLS
TO BRING SERVICES TO CHILDREN
AND USE WHERE THEY ARE
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN'S IN CALIFORNIA.
AGE FOUR TO ELEVEN HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
OVER 70% OF THEM NEVER RECEIVED
ANY TREATMENT.
THE PERCENTAGE SHOWN TO ME.
UP 280% OR HIGHER FOR USE IN
PROPERTY AND DOES -- WITH THE
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING PARENTS.
SO OVER THE LAST DECADE SUICIDE
RATE AMONG CHILDREN SEVENTEEN
AND YOUNGER HAVE INCREASED BY
84%.
THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
PROVIDING SERVICES ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES.
BREAK DOWN THE BAY AREA TO
ASSESS.
BUT BURIED FILL SCHOOL IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE ENOUGH OF THOSE
SO.
STAFF TO PROVIDE TIME THESE
SERVICES TO OUR STUDENTS.
AB EIGHT WILL PROVIDE A BASELINE
REQUIREMENT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT IN SCHOOL FOR CHILDREN'S
AND USE ACROSS THE STATE.
THIS BILL WOULD DO RIGHT FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT THEY
NEED ON THEIR CAMPUSES.
SO WHAT WAS ME HERE TODAY. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS IT IVAN.
CARILLO ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS.
AND ANITA AVERAGE.
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE PGA.
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER ALL
RIGHT TO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH I'LL LET YOU DECIDE WHO
GOES FIRST.
MORNING -- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE ONE CARRY
ON WITH THIS CESSATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT AS YOU ARE WELL AWARE
EDUCATORS ARE ARE RESPONDING TO
HISTORIC RATES OF OF TRAUMA
DEPRESSION ANXIETY AND SUICIDE
IDEATION -- MY COLLEAGUES AND I
CAN'T GO ANYWHERE IN THE STATE
WITHOUT HEARING GUT WRENCHING
STORIES RELATED TO STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH -- STUDENTS THAT
ARE EXPERIENCING ANXIETY TO THE
OF OF OF IT RESULTING IN
TEMPORARY PARALYSIS -- WE'VE
HEARD STORIES OF STUDENTS
ATTEMPTING TO COPE WITH THE LOSS
OF OF OF FRIENDS WHO DIED IN
RECENT FOUGHT WILD FIRES -- I
HEARD A STORY VERY RECENTLY.
OF A YOUNG MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENT --
WHO RAN OUT OF A SCHOOL ALL
SCHOOL ASSEMBLY AND ATTEMPTED TO
HANG HERSELF ON ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS FROM A TREE -- IN AND
IT'S WHAT'S BECOME VERY CLEAR
THAT THESE ARE HAPPENING IN
ISOLATION THESE ARE EXCEPTIONS
TO THE RULE I'M STORIES LIKE
THESE ARE ARE BECOMING THE NORM --
AND AND AS WELL INTENTIONED AS
EDUCATORS ARE -- ADMINISTRATORS
TEACHERS CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES IT
IT IT'S CLEAR THAT STUDENTS NEED
DIRECT ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
AND SCHOOLS ARE IN A REALLY
UNIQUE POSITION TO TO TO HOW IS
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS --
BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT STUDENTS SPEND ON CAMPUS.
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ARE
ABLE TO TO DEVELOP AND CULTIVATE.
I'M REALLY STRONG AND TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH WITH YOUTH
AND WITH PARENTS AND GUARDIANS --
BUT BUT SECONDLY IT'S ABOUT
ACCESSIBILITY -- MEN AND ALL TOO
OFTEN REFERRING -- SO YOUNG
PERSON OUT TO A COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICE IS INACCESSIBLE PARTS.
SIX IN RURAL AND REMOTE AREAS
WHERE THE NEAREST SERVICE
PRIVATE SERVICE PROVIDER CAN BE
THIRTY MINUTES AWAY -- SO WE WE
SUPPORT A BE A CAUSAL INCREASE
THE THE NUMBER OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ON ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AMOUNT OF TIME AND ATTENTION
THAT THIS BODY HAD HAS PUT ON
THE TOPIC AN APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THE
BILL WITH INSTRUCTS PART THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THE NEED OUR CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA -- OTHER LEADING SHALL LEVEL
BECAUSE THE ORGANIZATION WE HAVE
HAD A LONG HISTORY OF SUPPORTING
BOTH CHILDREN'S.
EDUCATION AND HEALTH IN ORDER TO
LEARN AT THEIR BEST CHILDREN
NEED TO BE HEALTHY.
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IT'S BEEN AN
AREA WHERE VAST NEEDS ARE UNMET
WHO ARE THESE CHILDREN.
THERE ARE THE BULLIES AND THE
BULLIED.
TRAUMA DRUG ABUSERS DEPRESSED
AND SUICIDAL OR FRIENDS THE
NEIGHBOR'S KIDS AT OUR OWN.
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA BETWEEN THE AGES
OF FOUR AND ELEVEN HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES BUT 70% TO NOT GET
SERVICES.
THAT NUMBER GROWS TO OVER 80%
UNSERVED WHEN THEY LIVE IN
POVERTY.
AB EIGHT HELPS TO REMEDY THE
SITUATION BY REQUIRING A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL ON CAMPUS OF
EVERY SCHOOL THESE PER.
COME FROM A VARIETY OF SOURCES
SOCIAL WORKERS NURSES
PSYCHIATRISTS PSYCHOLOGISTS
TRAINED AND SUPERVISED AT CHEN
FROM PEER GROUPS AND FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
THE POSSIBILITY OF PREVENTING
SUICIDE SELF HARM BOWLING
REDUCING DRUG ABUSE OR SIMPLY
INTERVENING IN A LOW MOMENT.
CAN BE AN ALL LIFE ALTERING.
SITUATION FOR THE STUDENTS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA MEMBERS IN
THE RESOLUTION SCHOOL BASED LINK.
HEALTH CENTERS WE BELIEVE ARE WE
STATE OUR BELIEF THAT ALL
CHILDREN ARE ENTITLED TO
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
AND RECOGNIZE SCHOOL IS THE
IDEAL PLACE TO OFFER THE
SERVICES WE SUPPORT THE
APPROPRIATION OF STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING. TO EXPAND THE
CARE FOR MENTALLY ILL CHILDREN.
AND YOU WE LOOK AT TO ATTAIN
QUALITY.
COUNSELING AND GUIDANCE SERVICES
AND STUDENT HEALTH SERVICES
PROVIDED BY CREDENTIALED
PERSONNEL.
ARE CHILDREN WHO NEED THE
INTERVENTION OF A CARING AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER CAN GET HELP.
IF NO ONE SEES THEM PUTTING MORE
EYES FROM CARING ADULTS ON OUR
KIDS MOVE THE NEEDLE FOR THESE
CHILDREN OUR CHILDREN DESERVE NO
LESS WE THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
FOR ITS ONGOING WORK TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO MENTAL CARE SERVICES
ON SCHOOL.
CAMPUSES THE NEXT BIG COMMITTEE
FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU HE DID GREAT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS VINCE WERE UP MUCH OF
WHAT THE WHITE AND GROUP ON
BEHALF OF NEXT GEN CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
I AM WORKING WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AN HONORABLE MEMBERS
DANNY OFFER FROM PLATINUM VISORS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS.
ON THE CALIFORNIA AND ALSO AS A
PROUD DAD IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ERICA HOFFMAN TO BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE PREVIOUSLY HAD
OPPOSED POSITION ON THE MEASURE
BUT I DO WANT TO THANK --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND HIS
STAFF FOR THE MOMENT THEY HAVE
TAKEN IN THE BILL AND WE ARE
REMOVING THAT OPPOSITION SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TERRIFIC
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MAKE MAKE A LITTLE ROOM AT THE
TABLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU. TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH A LAKESIDE HIS
STARTS. TWENTY SIGNING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BE ABLE HEALTH AGENCY -- WE
OPPOSE A. B. A. REGRETFULLY --
WE SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF
EXPANDING THE NUMBER MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES BUT WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THE FUNNY SOURCE
APPROPRIATE SPECIALLY -- FOR NON
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL SUCH
AS SCHOOL NURSES AND NOW WE LOOK
FOR TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON
FINDING A MORE APPROPRIATE
SOURCE OF FUNDING THANK YOU.
YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
DANIEL A CALIFORNIA LINES OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
UNFORTUNATELY I ALSO HAVE TAKEN
OPPOSITION FOR THE SAME REASONS
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER STATED.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE SCOPE
OF PRACTICE AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE TRAINED
TO DELIVER THE SERVICES ARE THE
ONES RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DELIVERY AND AND BILLING OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE THAT
CONCERN ABOUT THE USE OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT FUNDS
WHICH ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
DESIGNATED TO COUNTIES IN
ALLOCATED THROUGH A LOCAL
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
BASED UPON THEIR LOCAL AREA
NEEDS -- A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS
ARE ALREADY IN EXISTENCE AND
THEY'RE DOING SOME WONDERFUL
WORKING COUNTIES.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU IS
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING MEN WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY.
SENATOR PAM.
THANK YOU AND SOME THEIR SHORT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I PREVIOUSLY AUTHORED
ADULT ACTUALLY -- DO A PILOT
WHERE WE WOULD HAVE A MENTAL
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL NURSE AND
AND AND DAILY SEVERAL SCHOOLS.
TO SHOW WE CAN IMPROVE BETTER
OUTCOMES OF CERTAINLY THIS IS IN
LINE WITH THAT -- A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL AND
AGAIN -- SUPPORT WE TRY TO DO
WITH THE BILL FIRST OF ALL IN
TERMS OF ASSEMBLY RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING SOMEONE ON
SITE SPECIALLY FOR A LARGER
SCHOOL. FOR SMALLER SCHOOLS A
RURAL SCHOOLS CAN THEY USE
TELEHEALTH FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS A WAY TO PROVIDE
THAT AXIS OF THAT BE ALLOWED
UNDER YOUR BILL.
DEFINITELY DO YOU KNOW WHATEVER
TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE.
BUT THIS BILL WAS THE ANTI THE
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO HAVE
SOME.
LIVE.
BODY YOU KNOW ED IN THIS TO
SCHOOL TO HELP IDENTIFY.
THE A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE ON A
VERY VERY EARLY FINE SO THEN WE
CAN GO TO A YOU KNOW FURTHER.
ASSISTANCE OKAY WELL I'M I I
GUESS I IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
FIGURE ACCESS PARTICULARLY IN
MORE RURAL COMMUNITIES WHERE.
MAYBE SMALLER SCHOOLS ARE MORE
SPREAD OUT THE ABILITY TO USE --
MECHANISMS LIKE TELEHEALTH WHICH
IS WHICH HAVE BEEN TESTS NOW
PEOPLE OF EXAM AND MIGHT BE A
WAY -- TO TO CHEAT.
THE BILL THAT'S WHY I WAS ASKING
THAT QUESTION NOW RECOGNIZING
VIA SCHOOL SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE
SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS AT THAT
RATIO YOU MAYBE IF YOU CAN GET
PERSONAL SITE THAT'S GREAT BUT
LAW SCHOOLS ARE SMALLER AND AND
SAID AND ALSO VERY DISTANT FROM
EACH OTHER SO I KNOW YOU.
ALLOW ONE PERSON THE COVER
MULTIPLE SCHOOLS AND WE SEE THE
STRUGGLE SCHOOL NURSES TO RATE
IN FACT ACTUALLY -- PRESS
ANOTHER BILL SHOULD BE THE RATIO
OF SCHOOL NURSES TO STUDENTS AS
WELL I KNOW THAT'S BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF YOUR BILL -- SO I JUST
WANT TO CHECK IN ON THAT AND
THEN I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION
IS IS THAT -- YEAH I I DO SHARE
THE CONCERN OF THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT THIS AND I REALIZE THIS
WASN'T BY YOUR REGIONAL BILL I
THINK THIS WAS PUT ON YOUR BILL
LATER ON WAS USING THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT MONEY.
EVERYONE GOES THAT WELL WITH A
LOT OF BILLS I SERVE ON THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE EVERYONE
SAYS OH LOOK ABOUT POT OF MONEY
WILL TAKE SOME.
BUT AS WE KEEP DIPPING INTO THAT
POT FOR YOU KNOW MENTAL HEALTH
pWHAT ALREADY THINGS MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE ETCETERA -- ASM
LOW CONCERNED ABOUT.
DESIGNATING THAT SPECIFIC PART
OF MONEY THE MONEY WOULD HAVE TO
COME OUT OF AND AND MAYBE BEING
A LITTLE MORE AGNOSTIC ABOUT
THAT I REALIZED IT WASN'T YOUR
REGIONAL PART OF YOUR BILL THAT.
WAS PROBABLY INCLUDED BY
COMMITTEE THAT IT HAD TO GO
THROUGH ON THE WAY OVER HERE --
BUT PERHAPS WE CAN HAVE SOME
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
THE LATER ON BUT CERTAINLY BE
HAPPY TO MOVE TO BUILD
APPROPRIATE TIME AND AGAIN THE
ANSWER FOR THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
DEFINITELY OF DE ID TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AT THAT AUDIT SHOWS
DRIVE WE HAVE ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
ON SPEND IN ON THIS -- A MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE ACT MONEY ON THE
TABLE.
SO I I KNOW WILL DETECT LIKE IN
ANY BILLS THAT THEY REQUIRE THE
THE THE THE PHYSICAL WHO.
WOULD SUPPORT OR A BUDGETARY
SUPPORT.
IT IS IN A VERY COMPETITIVE
PROCESS.
SO BUT IT I FELT THAT THE IT
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT IS
A CRITICAL ISSUE.
AND I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS IT AND
AND THE SCHOOL WERE GOOD ONE AT
THAT I DIDN'T SEE THAT COMING TO
OUR HOUSE.
ACTUALLY THERE'S A VERSION
COMING TO YOUR HOUSE THAT'S ALL
OKAY ALL RIGHT I SHOULD JUST
WISHES TO COME TRUE.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
DESERVE THE GANNETT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT.
ISSUE OF BECAUSE OF THE TO THE
GREAT NEED IN OUR COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY I THINK A LOT OF THE
SOCIAL PROBLEM IS THE STARTED
WITH SOME MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE.
AND IT WOULD BE -- EARLIER THAT
WE CAN HELP THEM AND I THINK.
THIS.
WOULD BE MUCH BETTER TO PREVENT
A LOT OF TRAGEDIES IN SCHOOL AND
ALSO IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO I I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I WILL.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER TO HAVE
A MOTION MEMBERS.
THANK YOU THE BILLS BY MOVE BY
SENATOR PAN MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM ONE AB
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
HEALTH LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK AYE
CHANGE CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
PAN AYE.
THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT
BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
HE HAS ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB.
THREE I DON'T FIVE EXCUSE ME AB
THREE FIFTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MADAM CHAIR I HAVE TWO ITEMS
WOULD IT BE OKAY IF ICE LEAD
WITH THE OTHER TO MY WITNESS
CURRENTLY.
SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH ITEM
FOURTEEN AB EIGHT OH NINE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS A PRETTY
SIMPLE BILL ALL IT REQUIRES IS
PUBLIC -- COLLEGES TO POST TITLE
NINE PROTECTIONS SO THAT
STUDENTS WHO ARE PREGNANT
ACTUALLY NO -- WITH THE
PROTECTIONS ARE THAT THEIR WORK
COULD BE ACCOMMODATED AND
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS COULD
BE MADE A PRETTY SOON THE
CURRENTLY NOT WHICH THAT
SURPRISES ME -- BUT IT ALSO --
ENCOURAGES LOCAL CAMPUSES -- TO
PRIORITIZE A SINGLE MOTHERS
GETTING CHILDCARE ALSO THE
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION.
I RESPECT LAST FOR MY VOTE AND
HAVE A A WITNESS.
THANK THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARIA JOSE
FERNANDEZ FLORES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE.
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
OR NINE BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN
THE EMPOWERMENT OF WOMEN AND
FAMILIES AND SUPPORT THE RIGHTS
AND PROTECTIONS. TO BECOME
SUCCESSFUL IN HIGHER EDUCATION
SINGLE PARENTS COMPRISE A
GROWING PERCENTAGE OF COLLEGE
STUDENTS BUT OBTAINING A DEGREE
WHILE JUGGLING THE DEMANDS OF
PARENTHOOD.
BECAUSE OF SOME STUDENTS TO DROP
OUT.
TITLE NINE EXISTS TO PROVIDE
RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS FOR
PREGNANT PARENTING STUDENTS.
HOWEVER MANY STUDENTS ARE
UNAWARE OF THIS IT IS VITAL THAT
OUR PUBLIC COLLEGES IN.
THIS OF THESE PROTECTIONS TO
ASSIST THE STUDENTS AND
COMPLETING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS. FOR THE MORE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES FACING SINGLE
PARENTS STUDENTS IN SECURING
AFFORDABLE AND FLEXIBLE CHILD
CARE.
PRIOR TO ENROLLMENT FOR SINGLE
LOW INCOME PARENTING STUDENTS
FOR ON CAMPUS CHILDCARE PROGRAMS
CAN HELP EASE THE BURDEN OF
SCHOOL SCHEDULES AND BEING
WAITLISTED FOR MONTHS.
THIS BILL HELPS SINGLE PARENTS
OVERCOME CHALLENGES THAT
OTHERWISE MAY HAVE CAUSED HIM TO
LEAVE COLLEGE.
AB ONLINE IS A MODEST YET
EFFECTIVE STEP TOWARDS
INCREASING STUDENT RETENTION AND
GRADUATION RATES AS SUPPORTERS
OF WOMEN IN COLLEGE IN OF ALL
SINGLE PARENTS I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING A MACKENZIE
CHRISTIAN CENTER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HOW IS IT ALL WITH THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
SUPPORT?
BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE
SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
ALEX BEFORE A WITH UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THE BILL HAS BEEN.
THE MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR CHIANG PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AND FOURTEEN AB EIGHT OR NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILK.
WILK I CHIANG CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
THE BILL IS IN A FULL SCALE BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL MOVE BACK NOW TO
ITEM FIVE AB THREE FIFTY SIX
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU -- THIS THIS IS ALSO
SIMPLE BILL I WOULD CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT -- TO
USE BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT --
DURING CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
EXCEEDING A ONE MILLION DOLLARS --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT IT ALSO
MIRRORS WHAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
ALREADY DONE FOR THE UC SYSTEM
AND LA U. S. D..
SO THANK YOU AND I ALSO HAVE A
WITNESS.
PLEASE RECEIVING YOU READY.
MORNING CARE ACROSS ON BEHALF OF
LA COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
VERSUS WANTED PAYING SOMEBODY
MEMBER SANTIAGO FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
HE STOPPED AND HE HAVE DONE.
THE VOTERS OF LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT VOTED
FOUR TIMES SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE TO SUPPORT THE
MODERNIZATION AND PHYSICAL
IMPROVEMENTS. TO LA CD'S NINE
COLLEGES.
LACC DISCOUNT.
THE THE TAX PAYERS INTERESTED IN
THEM.
LAT CDC'S BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT
AS IN OTHER TOOL TO USE UNDER
THE RIGHT CIRCUMSTANCES TO
ENSURE THEY ARE GETTING THE MOST
FOR TAXPAYERS PRECIOUS DOLLARS.
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS LEC CD
WILL BE CONTRACTING THREE POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS FOR MUCH
NEEDED PRODUCT PROJECTS
INCLUDING.
THE NEWS HE'S OUR SHOP IS
ADMINISTRATION BUILDING THIS NEW
FACILITY WILL SUCH CENTRALIZE
ALL SUPPORT SERVICES LIKE
COUNSELING AND FINANCIAL AID.
NURSING ALLIED HEALTH AND EASE
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY COLLEGE A
NEW BUILDING WITH ALL STATE OF
THE ART CLASSROOMS AND LABS
CRITICAL FOR TODAY'S STUDENTS TO
BE READY TO JOIN TOMORROW'S
WORKFORCE.
AGRICULTURAL EDUCATION CENTER AT
PIERCE COLLEGE TO PROVIDE A NEW
HOME AND ALL AMENITIES NEEDED
FOR STUDENTS IN AGRICULTURE
RELATED FIELD -- THIS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE
AN EDUCATIONAL WORK FOR
SUPPORTING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED MILLION
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY.
LA SEE CITY IS ALSO PLANNING ONE
BILLION WORTH OF INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADES TO OUR AGING COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
THE STUDENTS AND THE FACULTY
DESERVE THE BEST TEAM TO WORK ON
THESE PRODUCTS PROJECTS LACC
DVDS A FLEXIBILITY PROVIDED BY
A. B. THREE FIFTY SIX TO
EVALUATE BIDS BASED ON NON COST
FACTORS.
SUCH AS QUALIFICATIONS AND
SKILLS TIMELINESS LABOR COMPLY.
FIFTY AND THE PAST PERFORMANCE
TO INSURE TOP QUALITY WORK.
AT THE COUNTIES LOOK AT THE
COUNTY COUNTRY'S LARGEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
ONE OF ITS MOST DIVERSE THE BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT METHOD WILL
ALLOW LACC DE TO PROVIDE IS
MILLIONS OF STUDENTS WITH HIGH
QUALITY FACILITIES.
WHICH ENHANCER OVERALL EDUCATION
EXPERIENCE FOR THESE REASONS WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
WE LIKE TO THINK OF A A SEVEN
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS A
MEASURE FOR WE'VE ENJOYED OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH HIM.
THROUGH HIS TIME ON THE BOARD
AND THROUGH ITS TIME THE
LEGISLATURE -- WE THINK BEST
VALUE IS OF VERY GOOD THE FAX --
BACK THAT UP -- BEING ABLE TO
PRE QUALIFIED BIDDERS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE -- READY AND ABLE
AND WILLING TO DO THE WORK --
ANY COUPLE THAT WITH THE USE THE
REQUIREMENT TO USE A SKILLED
FRAMEWORK FOR SO THAT THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WHO ARE
DOING THE PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
GRADUATED HAVE.
ARE GRADUATES OF STATE WITH THE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS.
YOU'RE GONNA GET GOOD VALUE FOR
YOUR TAXPAYER DOLLAR WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
SIEMENS OR ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL [inaudible]
PROCEED WITH.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR IN
MEMBERS CAME STONE ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WELL WE SUPPORT IN
THEORY THAT IDEA OF BEST VALUE
CONSTRUCTION METHODS.
THIS PARTICULAR BILL ON PAGES
EIGHT AND NINE OR SEVEN EIGHT
EIGHT NINE CONTAINS PROVISIONS
FOR PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT --
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FEEL THAT THOSE --
AGREEMENTS DISADVANTAGE THEM AND
THEIR MEMBERS IN -- COMPETING
FOR THESE PROJECTS FOR FOR THOSE
REASONS WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR ALSO.
YES I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL -- I BELIEVE VERY
STRONGLY IN THE IDEA OF GETTING
THE BEST VALUE AND SPREADING THE
OF FACTORS THAT ARE NEEDED AND
NOT JUST LOWEST BIDDER.
I HAVING BEEN ON MANY
COMMISSIONS AND BOARDS A THE LA --
AIRPORT -- COMMISSION A AND ON
DOWN THE LINE I ALWAYS FOUND
THAT IT CAME BACK TO HAUNT US
WHEN WE WENT FOR LOWEST CHEAPEST
IT DIDN'T MATTER IT WAS ALWAYS
SOMETHING THAT REALLY HURT US IN
THE END.
I THINK THIS IDEA OF GETTING THE
BEST VALUE -- SHOULD BE SPREAD.
EVEN THE CONSTRUCTION OF
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY --
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS I THINK IT
SHOULD BE USED AS A MODEL FOR
ALL OF THE WORK THAT -- AND
CONTRACTS THAT OUR GOVERNMENT IN
CAGES AND SO I'D BE PROUD TO
MOVE THE BILL.
THIRD THING IS A RAZA CENTER
WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. SIX YEARS
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD ONE
OF MY FRUSTRATIONS AS WE HAD TO
TAKE THE LOW BID.
AND THERE'S ONLY TWO TIMES WE'RE
ABLE TO KICK IT OUT BECAUSE
THERE'S CLEARLY NOT -- NOT TRUE --
AS YOU KNOW THE WORST WORDS YOU
CAN HEAR IS THE TRUSTEES CHANGE
ORDER.
AND SO -- SO THIS CONCEPT IS
GREAT CONCEPT I BELIEVE THIS IS
ALSO A PILOT PROGRAM IS A PIPE
ORGAN CRACKER HOW MANY YEARS --
YOU KNOW LIKE SKIP THREE SO
THAT'S A I'M NOT GONNA HOLD YOU
TO IT SO IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM SO
IT WOULD HAVE TO COME BACK AT A
LATER DATE.
AND IT IS AT THIS POINT JUST
HOUSE WITHIN THE LA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT RIGHT WELL I
THINK THIS IS A WORTHY MODEL TO
TAKE A LOOK AT TO SEE IF IT
SHOULD BE REPLICATED STATEWIDE
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTIVE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER WILK ANYTHING
ELSE THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DORADO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHICH I TO CLOSE I THANK YOU ARE
RESPECT TO ASPEN I BOTH VERY
GOOD MAN SECRETARY WAS CULTURAL.
ITEM FIVE AB THREE FIFTY SIX THE
MOTION IS.
TO LARA LEYVA LEYVA AYE WILK AYE
WILK HI CHANGE CHIANG I'D
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL I'D GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
BELIEVE THAT BILL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
VERY WELCOME.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER I SEE YOU
OUT THERE COME ON DOWN YOU HAVE
ITEMS SIX WHICH IS AB.
THREE SIXTY NINE PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING A TEACHER LEYVA AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB THREE SIX NINE A BILL
RELATING TO THE STRUCTURE OF
SALARIES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SUPPORT STAFF.
EVIDENTLY STRONG EVIDENCE
STRONGLY SUGGESTS TO SEE ISSUE
IS THE ONLY CALIFORNIA STATE
AGENCY THAT DOES NOT PROVIDE
SALARY STEPS TO IT'S ME IT'S
STAFF.
THIS CREATES AN INVERSION SOURS
WERE NEW HIRES ARE EARNING MORE
THAN EXPERIENCE EMPLOYEES.
FOLLOWING THE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX IMPASSE ON CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS.
THIS ISSUE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
UNILATERALLY ELIMINATED EXISTING
EMPLOYEES OUR STEPS INCREASING
INCREASES TIES TO JOB
PERFORMANCE AND LONGEVITY.
THIS HAS RESULTED IN NEW HIRES
EARNING HIGHER SALARY THAT
EXISTING EMPLOYER.
IN THE SAME CLASSIFICATION FOR
MANY YEARS.
THIS IN EQUITY HAS CREATED A
NINETY FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN VERSION GAP.
BETWEEN THE SALARIES OF NEWLY
HIRED AND LONG EMPLOYED IN A CSU
STAFF.
WHILE DEALING WITH THE RESULTS
OF THE INVERSION WILL BE
NECESSARY THIS PARTICULAR BILL
ONLY SIX TO ADDRESS THE ONGOING
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM CONTRIBUTING
TO THE INVERSION AND HOPEFULLY
PREVENT IT FROM GETTING WORSE.
BUT TWO DECADES THIS ISSUE HAS
BEEN UNWILLING TO REINSTATE
SALARY STEPS DESPITE THE FAILURE
THE FAILURE OF THE EXISTING
SALAS STRUCTURE AND THE
INABILITY OF EMPLOYEES EARN A
FAIR AND EQUITABLE WAIT.
AB THREE SIX NINE WILL INSTITUTE
WE WILL REINSTATE A 5% SALARY
STEP FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SUPPORT STAFF.
THIS INCREASE WILL BE MADE
ANNUALLY WHEN EMPLOYEES MEET THE
STANDARDS WAS SATISFACTORY
PERFORMANCE AS DETERMINED BY THE
EMPLOYEES SUPERVISOR.
WITH ME TODAY TO GO TO SUPPORT
AB THREE SIX NINE IS MATT MASON
A TEAMSTER MEMBER AND THE
SUPERVISING ADULT.
EQUIPMENT MET MIKE MECHANIC AT
SAKS STATE.
AND FOR TECHNICAL SUPPORT I HAVE
WITH ME DAVID BELL HAWKINS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES UNION
MATT BROAD WHO IS REPRESENTING
THE TEAMSTERS AND KIMBERLY
ROLLED ROSENBERG BUT AS HE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MEMBERS THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MATT MASON I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB.
THREE SIXTY NINE I AM
SUPERVISING AUTO MECHANIC AT
SACRAMENTO STATE AND I'VE BEEN A
LOYAL AND DEDICATED EMPLOYEE FOR
THE LAST SEVENTEEN YEARS.
I'VE SUPPORTED MY WILL CO
WORKERS UNION STORE FOR TWELVE
AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
TEAMSTERS LOCAL TWENTY TEN WHICH
REPRESENTS ALL SKILLED TRADE
WORKERS ACROSS THE CSU SYSTEM.
MERRITT STEP INCREASES ARE THE
ONLY WAY FOR ME TO MAKE A FAIR
WAGE ADVANCE THROUGH MY PAY
RANGE.
MY WAGES ARE LIMITED BY MY TRADE
AS A MECHANIC AND FOR EXAMPLE I
CANNOT INVEST ANOTHER LIFETIME
TO LEARN HOW TO BECOME
ELECTRIFYING OR A LOCKSMITH.
THE I HAVE MOVED UP TO THE TOP
POSITION MY TRADE BY SUPERVISOR
AND I KNOW WE DO PROGRESS
THROUGH THE SALARY RANGE.
WHEN IT DID BECOME A SUPERVISOR
I WAS LIMITED IN MY PAY BY A
DIRECTOR WHO SAID I COULDN'T
MAKE MORE MONEY THAN THE PLUMBER
OR A PAINTER -- I'VE DEDICATED
ALMOST TWO DECADES OF MY LIFE TO
SEX STATE AND THERE IS NO REWARD
FOR WORKING HARD.
IN RANGE PROGRESSION. FOR ALL MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS HERE AT THE
C. ISSUE ARE FEW AND FAR BETWEEN
AND DENIED YEAR AFTER YEAR -- IN
A VOICE BEEN BASED ON FINANCIAL
REASONS OR THEY JUST CAN'T START
GIVING RAISES TO ONE PERSON
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO GIVE IT
TO EVERYBODY -- AFTER MARRIAGE
STEP INCREASES WERE DISAPPEARED
WE STARTED SEEKING AN INVERSION
WE STARTED SEEING AN INVERSION
PROBLEM AT OUR CAMPUS.
AND I HAVE A THREE YEAR AUTO
MECHANICS MAKING AS MUCH
[inaudible]
PRINT.
AND BUILDING SERVICE ENGINEERS
WHO RETIRED AFTER TWENTY FOUR
YEARS ARE NOW MAKING THE SAME
WAGE AS THEIR REPLACEMENT WAS
HIRED AT THIS IS NOT THE WAY THE
SYSTEM'S SUPPOSED TO WORK.
THIS IS ABOUT FAIRNESS AND BEING
EQUAL IN COMPETITIVE.
WITH THE REST OF THE CIVIL
SERVICE WORKERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY AGENCY IN
DEPARTMENT HAS STEP INCREASES
EXCEPT US SO PLEASE HELP US IN
THIS UNFAIRNESS.
I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WITNESS.
THERE IS A REGULAR THAT'S YEAH
YOU PROJECT COSPONSORED HERE
JUST FOR TECHNICAL SUPPORT.
VIEW.
DAVID BELL HOP INTO THIS ISSUE
EMPLOYEES UNION -- SPONSOR OF
LEGISLATION AS THE BEST INTO ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROAD
FOR THE TEAMSTERS UNITE HERE.
THE MACHINE IS UTILITY WORKERS
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AMY HEINZ PSYCH WITH THE
UNIVERSITY PROFESSIONAL AND
TECHNICAL IN PLACE YOU W. A
LOCAL NINETY ONE NINETEEN IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. THIRTY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL
.
GOOD MORNING PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY TWO MINUTES EACH.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ALLEN SEES HIM
HE'S ALREADY MAN RIGHT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THE CSU OPPOSES THIS BILL FOR
SEVERAL REASONS FIRST WE HAVE
HEARD THE BILL FRAMED AS A MEANS
OF ASSISTING OUR LOWEST WAGE
WORKERS.
AND ADDRESSING SALARY INVERSIONS.
IN REALITY THE STAFF WHO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL GO BEYOND
OUR LOWEST PAID EMPLOYEES SUCH
AS GROUNDSKEEPERS AND CUSTODIANS.
TO INCLUDE ARE HIGHLY HIGHLY
COMPENSATED EMPLOYEES SUCH AS
ACCOUNTANTS ENGINEERS AND IT
PERSONNEL. FOR THE MORE THE BILL
WOULD INCREASE THE SALARIES OF
ALL STAFF AT THE SAME RATE
ANNUALLY.
THE EFFECT WOULD BE TO
PERPETUATE AND COMPOUND ANY
SALARY INEQUITIES THAT MAY EXIST
AS A RESULT OF INVERSION IT FOR
COMPRESSION.
SECONDLY THE COST IMPACTS OF THE
BILL ARE SIGNIFICANT AND WHILE
THIS IS A POLICY COMMITTEE IS
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT ANY
EXPENSES. FOR THIS BILL.
WOULDCOME AT THE EXPENSE OF
OTHER POLICY PRIORITIES SUCH AS
THE HIRING OF TENURE FACULTY OR
STUDENT SUCCESS.
WE ESTIMATE THE COST TO BE
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION IN THE
FIRST YOU'RE GOING TO ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION.
FINALLY THE IN PERHAPS THE MOST
IMPORTANT REASON WE OPPOSE THE
BILL IS IT UNDERMINES OUR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS.
THIS IS OF PARTICULAR CONCERN AS
OUR THREE YEAR CONTRACTS WE
CURRENTLY HAVE WITH OUR
BARGAINING UNITS EXPIRE IN THE
NEXT YEAR.
THE BILL SO THE DANGERS
PRESIDENT UNDERMINES THE EFFORTS
OF OUR BOARD TO NEGOTIATE FAIR
COMPENSATION WITHIN THE FISCAL
REALITIES OF OUR FUNDING NOT
ONLY WAS CSU REVIEW.
BUT WITH ALL OTHER BARGAINING
UNITS AS WELL WITH ME TODAY IS
JOHN'S WERE BACK THIS UC'S
ASSOCIATE VICE CHANCELLOR OF
LABOR AND EMPLOYEE RELATIONS AND
OUR LEAD NEGOTIATOR. TO DISCUSS
THE FURTHER IMPLICATIONS OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED MORNING.
SO THERE WAS A REASON WHY THE
BOARD MOVED FROM THE STEPPING
CREASES TO OPEN RANGES AND THAT
WAS BECAUSE THE STATE
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE WAY
THAT IT FUNDED THE CSU.
UP UNTIL THAT POINT OUR FUNDING
WAS DERIVED LARGELY FROM A
SERIES OF FORMULAS.
AND THAT WAS KNOWN AS ORANGE
BOOK FUNDING.
AND AS PART OF THAT PROCESS
THESE -- INDIVIDUAL SALARY
INCREASES.
I RIGHTLY BY THE STATE SO IT WAS
A LINE ITEM IN OUR BUDGET.
DURING ONE OF THE RECESSIONS IN
THE NINETIES THE STATE.
DECIDED THAT THE CENTURY THE CSU
WOULD JUST RECEIVE A BLOCK OF
MONEY AND WE DON'T HAVE TO
ALLOCATE HOW WE SPEND THAT MONEY
BASED ON OUR COMPETING
PRIORITIES.
SO WITHIN THAT CONTEXT IT WAS
CONSIDERED BY POLICY TO BE --
GUARANTEEING SALARY INCREASES
WITHOUT THERE BEING ANY
CONCURRENT GUARANTEE AS TO
FUTURE REVENUES.
SO WE MOVED TO AN OPEN RANGE
SYSTEM.
AND THE RATIONALE FOR THAT MOVE
IS AS RELEVANT TODAY AS IT WAS
THEN -- I WAS ACTUALLY IN THE
ROOM DURING THE RECESSION WHEN
WE RECEIVE THE COLD TELLING US
THAT WE HAD TO BE CHIU SOUGHT
BUDGET BY FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS BEFORE THE
START OF THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
WHICH WAS A MATTER OF A FEW
WEEKS AWAY.
AND EVEN WITH WHAT I RECALL WITH
THE LARGEST TUITION INCREASES
AND SEE ISSUES HISTORY -- WE
STILL HAD TO TAKE OTHER
EXTRAORDINARY MATCHES I WAS THE
PERSON NEGOTIATED THE FELLOWS I
OVER SO MANY LAYOFFS WE HAD TO
DO.
AND EVEN WITH ALL OF THOSE
MEASURES IN PLACE THERE WAS
STILL.
A CLEAR REDUCTION IN OUR ABILITY
TO PROVIDE THE LEVEL OF SERVICES
WHICH WE ASPIRE TO PROVIDE TO
OUR STUDENTS.
SO TO THAT.
MOST OF THE STAFF EMPLOYEES
ENDED UP GOING SIX SHE IS
WITHOUT SALARY INCREASES -- WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT WAS A GREAT
BURDEN ON THEM.
HI AND AS THE ECONOMY IS PICKED
UP WE DID TAKEN.
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO TRY AND
ADDRESS THE RESIDUAL EFFECTS OF
THAT PERIOD.
WITH VERY DIFFERENT TO THE STATE
AGENCY IS MOST OF THE STATE
AGENCIES THE GOVERNOR WILL
NEGOTIATE WITH THE UNITS.
THEY'LL AGREE SALARY AND THEN
THE BUDGET WILL BE ALLOCATED TO
TO MEET THAT NEED.
WITH AS WE GET A LUMP OF MONEY
AND THEN WE HAVE TO NEGOTIATE
OUR SALARIES WITH OUR UNIONS.
AND THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT
THE MONEY WE RECEIVE WILL COVER
OUR ALL OUR PRIORITIES -- WHICH
ARE OFTEN COMPETING ON OLD ME T
MISSION CRITICAL YOUR TIME IS UP
SO IF YOU CAN WRITE A SEVEN
ABOUT ONE ADDRESS A VISION VERY
QUICKLY. ONE THING THAT HAS ME
MENTION THE PRIMARY DRIVER OF
INVASION IN THE CSU IS NOT
EXTERNAL HIRES ITS INTERNAL
HIGHS -- WE HAVE A SYSTEM WHICH
GIVES PRIORITY FOR HIGHER TO
EXISTING EMPLOYEES WE'VE
RECENTLY AGREED TO ANYONE
MEETING MINIMAL QUALIFICATIONS
GETS INTERVIEWED -- WE HAVE THE
VISION THE CPA THAT SAYS THAT IF
SOMEBODY MOVES TO BACK HIGHER
CLASSIFICATION. TO HAVE A SALARY
SET UP 5% ABOVE THE CURRENT
SALARY.
SO IF YOU RUN A DATE TO REPORT
TO THE INDIVIDUAL WILL LOOK LIKE
CAN YOU HIGHER INTO THE
CLASSIFICATION.
I WILL NOT REFLECT THE FIGHT
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN TWENTY OR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS SAID THIS IN A
DIFFERENT CLASS.
SO IN VERSION IS NOT JUST THE
CASE OF LOCAL MARKETS BEING SET
IT'S BY AND LARGE A CREATURE OF
OUR INTERNAL PRACTICES TO
INCREASE SOCIAL MOBILITY AMONGST
OUR STAFF EMPLOYEES.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
BEFORE I GO TO THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT -- THIS IS A
BIG PROBLEM AND WHEN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR
TEN YEARS AND YOU HAVE SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN WORKING FOR THREE
YEARS AND THEY MAKE THE SAME OR
VERY CLOSE TO IT.
IT CREATES A HUGE MORALE PROBLEM
AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING AS YOUR INTERNAL
STRUCTURE PROVENCHER INTERNAL
STRUCTURE IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU COULD FIX.
SO I'M JUST MAKING THAT COMMENT --
AS SOMEONE WHO WORKS IN THE
LABOR MOVEMENT FOR MANY YEARS
AND SAW WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU
HIRED SOMEONE AND THEY CAME IN
THEY WERE MAKING CLOTHES OR THE
SAME AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN THERE
FOR TEN OR TWENTY YEARS.
CREATES A HUGE MORAL PROBLEM IT
DOESN'T SHOW YOUR EMPLOYEES WHO
HAVE STAYED WITH YOU AND BEEN
THERE BEEN LOYAL WORKERS -- THAT
YOU VALUE THEM SO I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT THAT'S SOMETHING YOU
MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT OR I THINK
YOU WILL CONTINUE JUST.
LIKE THIS UNTIL WE SEE PARITY
WITH ADAM AND OPEN IT UP TO THE
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
CASING AND HEARING NONE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WHICH I TO CLOSE RIGHT I
WANT I WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO
CAME TODAY FOR THIS PARTICULAR --
PRESENTATION YOU KNOW I HAVE THE
THE GOOD FORTUNE I GUESS AND AND
AS SOMETIMES THE SAME CHALLENGE
OF HAVING WORKED FOR C. ISSUE
FOR FORTY YEARS AS A FACULTY
MEMBER.
AND AS A CHAIR OF A DEPARTMENT
AND I WAS THERE WHEN THIS TOOK
PLACE NOT ONLY DID IT HAPPEN TO
THIS GROUP BUT IT HAPPENED TO
OTHER GROUPS THROUGHOUT THE
SYSTEM THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE.
TO NEGOTIATE AND GET THERE'S
BACK OF THIS REMAINS A FINAL
GROUP THAT HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
GET THE BEARD INCREASE THIS IS
NOT AN AUTOMATIC INCREASE.
A THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE YOU
MARRIED AND YOU HAVE TO BE
EVALUATED IN ORDER TO GET IT AND
IT ONLY HAPPENS IF THE RESOURCES
ARE AVAILABLE.
SO IT'S NOT AN AUTOMATIC ACROSS
THE BOARD REYES -- IS PRETTY
MUCH SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DO HERE
IN THIS HOUSE WHEN WE EVALUATE
OUR OUR CURRENT STAFF -- WE MAY
GIVE THEM 5% OR 10% ADDITIONAL
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE WHAT THE
MARKET IS DOING BUT ALSO WITH
THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING IN
THE HOUSE AND THAT IS ON TOP OF
THE 2% OF 3% RAISE A WHATEVER
THAT'S THE THAT IS WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT -- THE CURRENT STRUCTURE
DOES NOT FACILITATE THE KIND OF
MORALE THAT WE TALK A OUT I KNOW
PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN THERE.
SINCE NINETY SIX AND WHO ARE
STILL.
IN WITH THE SAME SALARY AND THE
INVERSION PIECE THAT'S THERE --
THREE SIXTY TWO RETURNS POLICY
THAT WE HAD TO PAY EMPLOYEES AND
AT THE SAME WAY WE DO IT MANY OF
OUR MANAGEMENT WE GET THE MERIT
INCREASES 1020%.
OFTENTIMES TO THE PRESIDENT AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE CAMPUS
IS THAT OF THE I. WHY TO KEEP
THEM EMPLOYED JUST LET THEM KNOW
THAT THEY'VE DONE A GOOD JOB AND
TO MERIT IT.
THE 5% INCREASE IS ON PAR WITH
OTHER SEE ISSUE STAFF -- THAT
WAS THERE NINETY SIX AND IS IN
LINE WITH OTHER STATE EMPLOYEES
IN TERMS OF WHAT AMERICA
INCREASE WOULD BE BUT IT IS NOT
AN AUTOMATIC INCREASE IT IS A
MERIT INCREASE.
AND AS CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENT I
HAD TO EVALUATE MY STAFF.
AND A AND A GREAT RECOMMEND WHAT
THE NOT THEY WOULD GET MARRIED
INCREASES THOSE WITH A WIN
NINETY SIX UNFORTUNATELY.
AGAIN THESE ARE AS I SAID THEY
WILL BE THEY WILL BE MARRIED
THEY WOULD NOT BE AUTOMATIC --
SEE ISSUE HAS UNILATERALLY
ELIMINATED THIS MERIT BASED STEP
SO INCREASES OUTSIDE OF THE
BARGAINING PROCESS AND THAT'S
WHAT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND WE
OFTEN HEAR THE ARGUMENTS THIS
SHOULD BE DONE IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IT WAS TAKEN AWAY
OUTSIDE OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
AND IT HAS AN AND DESPITE THE
EFFORTS TO TRY TO WORK TO BRING
IT BACK DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THIS HOUSE.
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY IN
THE LAST YEAR SO PASSED THIS
BILL UNANIMOUSLY IN THE GOVERNOR
VETOED IT BASICALLY EMPHASIS --
KIND OF REFERRING TO THE FACT
THAT HEY YOU.
TO PAY ATTENTION. TO THIS IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING BUT THREE
YEARS THEY STILL HAVE NOT TAKEN
THE ISSUE UP AND THEY'VE NOT
DONE IT AND IT'S NOT LIKELY
BASED ON THE CONVERSATION WE
HEAR THAT THEY WILL TAKE IT UP
AGAIN.
THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARY THING
THAT'S HAPPENING IN THE STATE
AND IT REQUIRES AN EXTRAORDINARY
MEASURE NORMALLY AS A SAID I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED WITH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WAS A PART OF THE
FACULTY WOULD CF.
WHEN THE CFA AND OTHERS GOT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNDERSTAND
THE PROCESS AND WHAT IT'S ALL
ABOUT BUT THIS IS A SITUATION
THAT IS REALLY EXTRAORDINARY AND
THEY HAVE STRUGGLE TO TRY TO DO
IT IN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING?
AND HAS NOT BEEN AN APPETITE ON
THE PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION
TO DO THAT AND SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT SHOULD GO IN THAT WAY THE
GOVERNOR HAS COSTLY MADE
REFERENCE TO IT WE HAVE MADE
REFERENCE TO IT AND IT HAS NOT
BEEN TAKEN UP.
SO AFTER THREE YEARS WE REALLY
NEED TO TAKE A STEP AND DO
SOMETHING ABOUT EMPLOYEES WHO
WORK FOR US AND HAVE BEEN DE
VALUED IN THIS PROCESS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK S. WHAT I VOTE
FOR AB.
THREE SIX NINE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY AS A SENATOR TO RAZA
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SIXTY THREE SIXTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL HI WILK HI CHIANG
LASSELL WHO WRESTLE AYE GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN.
BELIEVE THAT BILL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OUT ON THANK
YOU SIMPLY WOMAN.
ALL RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEN MEDINA I THINK I
SEE YOU DOWN THERE COME ON ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB.
FOR TWENTY EIGHT PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
YOUR GUIDE SPECIAL.
pMEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT AB FOR TWENTY
EIGHT WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING FOR THE EQUALIZATION.
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
RATES. FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL SERVICES AND FOR HIGH
COST PLACEMENTS.
OUR STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS DESERVE HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
BUT OUR CURRENT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING SYSTEM
PRESENTS BARRIERS WERE THERE
SHOULD BE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
DECADES CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING RATES HAVE
VARIED CONSIDERABLY WITHOUT ANY
RATIONALE.
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN LIVING WITH
THESE INEQUITIES FOR NEARLY FOUR
DECADES.
AND ADDRESSING THEM IS A SIMPLE
MATTER OF FAIRNESS [inaudible]
THE IN TWENTY STATE BUDGET IS
MAKING SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS TO
FIND PRESCHOOLERS WITH
DISABILITIES WHICH IS GREAT
PROGRESS.
BUT CURRENT FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION ALSO PRESENTS A
BERRIER AGAIN WHERE THERE SHOULD
BE OPPORTUNITY.
FINALLY THE BILL PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS WITH MORE SEVERE
DISABILITIES.
WHEN OUR CURRENT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCE SYSTEM WAS
ESTABLISHED WE HAD SUPPORT?
BUT IT WAS ELIMINATED DURING THE
RECESSION.
LEAVING SCHOOLS WITH NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
HIGHER CLASS PLACEMENTS.
ALL OF THE ADJUSTMENTS IN THIS
BILL ARE COMMONSENSE INVESTMENTS
IN FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY FOR
VALUED STUDENTS.
WITH ME TODAY IS MORE RAIN
O'LEARY BURNESS CO EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
TASK FORCE ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND DOCTOR SERRA COLLEGIAN
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE FOLSOM.
CORDOVA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GOOD MORNING TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH I'LL
LET YOU DECIDE TO START.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ENOUGH FOR THIS BILL AND THANK
YOU CHAIR AND AND MEMBERS FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY -- IT I DID
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE
CO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
STATEWIDE SPECIAL A TASK FORCE.
IN.
A TO PROVIDE SOME -- A SENSE OF
THE TIMELINE ABOUT SPECIAL AND
FUNDING OVER TIME.
SO THE STATE WIDE TASK FORCE WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN WHICH WAS THE SAME YEAR
THAT LCF OUT BEGIN ITS FUNDING
ABOUT EQUALIZING GENERAL
EDUCATION COSTS.
SO WE SPENT OVER TWO AND A HALF
YEARS DOING RESEARCH HAVING
PUBLIC INPUT WORKING WITH OVER
FIFTY PEOPLE INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
LEGISLATURE.
IN MADE MULTIPLE RECOMMENDATIONS
ESPECIALLY INCLUDING ARE
RELEVANT TODAY FISCAL
RECOMMENDATIONS.
SOARED TO MOST IMPORTANT FISCAL
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE.
EQUALIZATION OF FUNDING ACROSS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND IMPROVING
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION PRESCHOOL
FUNDING WHICH WAS PRETTY MUCH
NON EXISTANT.
SO IT BEFORE TWENTY EIGHT DOES
ADDRESS THESE WITH A PLAN TO
ADDRESS BOTH OF THOSE ISSUES.
I LOOKED AT THE ANALYSIS OF THE
BILL THAT WAS DONE ACT
EXCELLENTLY IN AND IT DOES
INCLUDE SOME OF THE HISTORY OF
SPECIAL ED FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE WAS THE
YEAR THAT EDUCATION FOR THE
HANDICAPPED ACT WAS PASSED AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL IN CALIFORNIA
AT THAT POINT SAID HOW DO WE
WHAT HOW DO WE DO THIS AND HOW
DO WE FUND IT.
ESTABLISH SYLLABUS AND IN ORDER
TO ESTABLISH THE FUNDING RATE AT
THAT.
S. DISTRICTS WHAT DID YOU SPEND
LAST YEAR ON YOUR SPECIAL ED AND
THAT'S HOW THEY DETERMINE THE
RATES FOR THE FUTURE.
SO FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
INEQUITIES IN FUNDING HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE I AM A OF
HIRED A BRAND NEW TEACHER AND
SERRA MAY HAVE HAD A THIRTY FIVE
YEAR TEACHER.
SO THAT THE COSTS WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT.
THEN THAT THOSE DIFFERENCES
BECAME EXACERBATED OVERTIME
BECAUSE COAL ON A HUNDRED
THOUSAND IS DIFFERENT THAN COAL
ON TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND AND SO
THAT LED TO AB SIX SO TWO WHICH
WAS ADOPTED IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN AND WE WENT TO A FUNDING
ON A K..
TWELVE K. TWELVE JUST FY I
YOU'RE EATING INTO YOUR
COLLEAGUES TIME SORRY.
OKAY SO THE THE INTENT LANGUAGE
IN AB SIX OH TWO FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING WAS THAT IT WAS THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
EQUALIZE SPECIAL ED PROGRAM
FUNDING IMBALANCES ENDS.
TO EQUALIZE PER PUPIL FUNDING SO
WE HAVE THIS HISTORY OF OUR
LEGISLATUREWANTING TO DO THAT.
THE RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN MEANT SPECIAL IT HAS NOT
HAD ANY FUNDING ADDED TO IT WALL
LCF OPPOSE FUNDED GENERAL AD.
SO WE'VE HAD MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS NO FUNDING WELL WE'VE HAD
INCREASES IN OUR SPECIAL THAT
NUMBERS.
GOOD THANK YOU HAVE A BETTER.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING AGAIN.
CHAIRPERSON HI LEYVA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SERRA COLLEGIAN
SUPERINTENDENT FOLSOM CORDOVA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK
YOU FOR IT HEARING THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND HOW IT IMPACTS DISTRICTS
SUCH AS MINE.
FOLSOM CORDOVA HAS OVER TWENTY
ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND OF THAT ABOUT THIRTEEN POINT
6% OR SPECIAL EDUCATION --
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED IN MY
BUDGET WE HAVE EXPENSES OF ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF
THAT FIFTY FIVE MILLION ARE
DISTRICT CONTRIBUTES ABOUT THAT
65%. TO COVER THAT COSTS THE
STATE WITH THE CURRENT FUNDING
STRUCTURE COVERS ABOUT 20%.
OF OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES FOLSOM CORDOVA HAS
SEEN SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN OUR
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WITH AUTISM
THIS IS BEEN A TREND STATEWIDE
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT STUDENTS
WITH AUTISM MADE UP 8% OF
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
IN THIS LAST YEAR STUDENTS WITH
AUTISM MADE UP 17% OF OUR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ALTHOUGH AUTISM FALLS ON THE
SPECTRUM MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
WITH AUTISM HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE NEEDS.
AND THEY REQUIRE MORE SERVICES
AND THEN STUDENTS WITH MILD
DISABILITIES.
FOLSOM CORDOVA HAS ALSO SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER STUDENTS REQUIRING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THE NUMBER
STUDENTS.
EDUCATIONALLY RELATED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR THEIR IP HAS
GROWN MORE THAN 6100%.
MANY OF THESE STUDENTS REQUIRES
SPECIALIZED PLACEMENT SECOND
COST ANYWHERE FROM FIFTY
THOUSAND TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PER YEAR AND MORE FOR
RESIDENTIAL PLACEMENT.
FOLSOM CORDOVA SPECIAL AT
FUNDING RATE IS FIVE HUNDRED SIX
DOLLARS PER ADA THERE ARE MANY
CELL BECAUSE I GET MEANT MUCH
MORE THAN WE DO AS HIGH AS NINE
HUNDRED PER ADA.
WHAT CALIFORNIA HAS PROVIDED
ONLY CALL IS ON SPECIAL ED
FUNDING OUR LOCAL CONTRIBUTION
INCREASES ANNUALLY AT ABOUT 12%
WHAT WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
NINETEEN TWENTY STATE BUDGET
LEVELING UP WITH SPECIAL ED
FUNDING BASE RATES TO THE STATE
WIDE TARGET -- THIS WILL ONLY
INCREASE OUR RATE BY FIFTY
DOLLARS PER ADA SO MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE FOR ALL THESE REASONS WE
STILL WE STILL NEED A BEFORE
TWENTY EIGHT TO PROVIDE EQUITY
AND SPECIAL AND FUNDING TO THE
NINETY FIFTH PERCENTILE IN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. FOR
STUDENTS WITH THE MOST NEED
THANK YOU.
YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CHAU MCANDREW HAD PROUD CO
SPONSOR THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FUNDING
COALITION AND TORRANCE AND
CLOVIS UNIFIED IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING PLAYED CONTRAST
FROM THE SUTTER COUNTY SOUTH.
AND THE THIRTEEN ELEAZAR SUTTER
COUNTY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ERICA HAVE BEEN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
MICHAEL SAYS THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE FORTY SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND KERN COUNTY.
WE SUPPORT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA.
A NEED EVER CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
WERE IN SUPPORT.
IN YOUR MAILLET CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NICK WRONGLY
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION IN SANTA CLARA SAN
DIEGO HUMBOLDT PLASTER AND
FRESNO COUNTIES THE SEAMY VALLEY
PASADENA ATASCADERO AND SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
AND THE SAN BERNADINO COUNTY
DISTRICT ADVOCATES FOR BETTER
SCHOOLS ALL IN SUPPORT.
RACHEL CIRCLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PRIVATE SPECIAL EDUCATION
SCHOOLS THE SCHOOL EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND A
SMALL SUCH A SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS A CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT.
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
SELF ADMINISTRATORS OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
THE TWENTY THREE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SUPERINTENDENTS AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT LIKE THAT
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
FORCE LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU.
MORNING ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
IN SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT.
THE SONG NOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MARTEL BUT ON BEHALF ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT.
COMPANY TOMORROW HERE BEHALF FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THEY LONNIE I CANNOT ON BEHALF
OF SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND FRESNO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERG WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION IN SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR NEED.
THING MINISTER IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
CNN WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY -- I
HAVE ONE OF MY CHILDREN SPECIAL
NEEDS WE WERE BLESSED TO GET
EARLY SERVICES WHICH HAD AN
IMMENSE IMPACT IN A POSITIVE WAY
ON OUR LIFE.
AND THIS IS A GREAT THE OTHER
THING WE NEED TO DO AND I HAVE A
RESOLUTION THIS CLEAR THE
SENTENCE CAN BE OVER IN THE SEMI
KNOW YOU BE SUPPORTIVE WHICH IS
CALLING ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO FULLY FUND ID E. A
IS SUPPOSED TO BE 40% IS AROUND.
10% SO BY MY CALCULATION WE'RE
LEAVING ABOUT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR -- OFF THE TABLE
AND YOU KNOW WE GOT A NANCY
PELOSI'S OR SPEAKER KEVIN
MCCARTY AS A MINORITY LEADER IN
THE HOUSE WE NEED BE PUTTING
PRESSURE ON THESE PEOPLE TO TO
DELIVER FOR OUR STUDENTS SO.
I COMMEND YOU FOR THIS AFRICAN
TO BE SUPPORTED THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR EFFORTS THANK YOU
SENATOR WELCOME CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO BE YOU
KNOW I THINK -- SUMMER MEDINA --
FOR BRING THIS BILL FORD IN
REFORMING THE SPECIAL IT FUNDING --
SYSTEM WHICH I THINK IS BROKEN
AND CERTAINLY IS A PEDIATRICIAN
TAKES CARE OF A LOT OF CHILDREN
SPECIAL NEEDS -- WHO ARE SPECIAL
EDUCATION RECOGNIZE WE NEED TO
HELP OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS I
GUESS I DID HAVE ONE QUESTION
ANSWERED SIR LATE?
THIS BILL THAT WE ACTUALLY VOTED
FOR PASSED HERE BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND UNDER THIS BILL.
THIS REQUIRES IN THE FULL FIRST
FISCAL YEAR FOLLOWING FULL
FUNDING TO LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
BUT WE ALSO JUST VOTED OUT THIS
COMMITTEE A BILL THAT MOVED UP
THE FULL FUNNY LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA UP TO SOMETHING
ITS ASPIRATIONAL AND CERTAINLY
WE SHOULD TRY TO ACHIEVE -- BUT
WITH THAT THEN THE LATE THIS
BILL I AM JUST THINKING ABOUT
THE INTERACTION BETWEEN THE TWO
BILLS -- AND I WOULDN'T WANT IT
DELAYED MOVEMENT OF SPECIAL ED
FUNDING BECAUSE WE STILL HADN'T
GOTTEN -- TO BUT ASSEMBLY IS
MADE -- TO THIRTY THREE BILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE AND AND WHICH
DEALT WITH I'VE BUT I THINK WE
VOTED FOR IT SO I THINK IT'S
NECESSARY BUT THEN YOU KNOW
TÁI TAKE AWHILE TO GET THERE
SO I I DO WILL JUST WANT TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUT.
IN TERMS OF YOUR BILL BEING SURE
THAT -- AS MUCH AS WERE
ASPIRATIONAL THAT WE ALSO DON'T
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS FOR
IMPORTANT BILL SAID IT BEFORE
YOU ANSWER SOME A MEMBER I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THE BILL THAT WE
JUST VOTED ON WAS INTENT
LANGUAGE ONLY.
SO I THINK WE'RE IN A GOOD SPACE
OKAY I REMEMBER WE WEREN'T IN
THE YEAH SOMETHING LIKE THAT
PRETTY MUCH ANSWERS A QUESTION.
GO.
WE'RE HERE TO HELP AND SENATE ED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR VERY
WELCOME.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS WITH THE
BILL BILLS REMOVE REJECT CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WELL I WANT TO THANK.
ALL OF WITNESSES HERE TODAY FOR
THEIR SUPPORT.
AND AND I SHARE WITH -- DOCTOR
PAN THAT IT IS BEYOND TIME THAT
WE DO WHAT'S FAIR FOR A SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM SEVEN A. B. FOR TWENTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK WILK I CHIANG
RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE GLAZER
MCGUIRE PAN AND I BELIEVE THAT
BILL OPEN OR THAT OPENED THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS AT
ON THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER.
I SEE ASSEMBLY WOMAN CAN SALAS
COME ON DOWN.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER NINE AB.
FIVE HUNDRED PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
MR HANDS GONNA GET TIRED OF ME
THIS MORNING -- SHOCKINGLY OF
ANOTHER BILL FOR WORKERS -- GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MANY PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE THAT SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES DO NOT HAVE PAID
PREGNANCY LEAVE IF A FEMALE
EMPLOYEES TO GET PREGNANT HAS
COMPLICATIONS DUE TO PREGNANCY
MISCARRIAGE.
FIRST SHE MUST FIRST USE HER
SICK AND VACATION LEAVE IF HE
HAS ANY AFTER THAT LEAVE IS
EXHAUSTED THEN SHE MAY GET
DIFFERENTIAL PAY WHICH IS HER
PAY MINUS THE COST FOR
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER. FOR UP TO
FIVE MONTHS IN A WORKFORCE THAT
IS OVER 70% FEMALE CURRENT LAW
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST WOMEN WHO
CHOOSE TO HAVE CHILDREN YOUNG
WOMEN SHOULD NOT BE PUT A
POSITION WHERE THEY MUST CHOOSE
BETWEEN SCHEDULING PREGNANCIES
BASED ON THE ACADEMIC YEAR
CALENDAR.
WAITING YEARS HAVE CHILDREN TILL
THEY SAVED ENOUGH SICK LEAVE ARE
TEMPTING TO SURVIVE WITHOUT
ADEQUATE PAY.
SCHOOLS AND ME COLLEGES CAN HELP
INSURE EMPLOYEES ARE INCENTIVIZE
TO REMAIN IN THE PROFESSION
ESPECIALLY AFTER THEY'VE HAD
CHILDREN BY INVESTING IN
NECESSARY BENEFITS AND MAKE IT
LESS BURDENSOME FOR YOUNG WOMEN
TO START A FAMILY.
STUDENTS CANNOT RECEIVE THE BEST
EDUCATION POSSIBLE OF OUR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CANNOT ATTRACT AND RETAIN GREAT
TEACHERS AB FIVE HUNDRED WOULD
ENSURE.
THAT'S POSSIBLE BY SIMPLY
RQUIRING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CHARTER SCHOOLS INCOMMUNICADO
JUST PROVIDE THEIR EMPLOYEES
WITH AT LEAST SIX WEEKS OF PAID
PREGNANCY LEAVE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MANAGER
MEMBERS BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA-FEDERATION OF TEACHERS --
ACCORDING TO LEARNING POLICY
INSTITUTE SOON IF THEY WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT TEACHER SHORTAGE --
YOUNG PEOPLE AREN'T SIMPLY BEING
DRAWN INTO THIS PROFESSION -- BY
LARGE ONE OF THE MAIN FACT OF
THAT IS THE LACK OF BENEFITS.
AND EVEN WHEN TEACHERS ARE
HIGHER SCHOOL STRUGGLE TO RETAIN
THEM.
WHICH NEGATIVELY IMPACTS
STUDENTS AND IMPOSES ADDITIONAL
COST -- ON THE DISTRICTS.
I WANT TO MENTION HIS COMMITTEE
THAT MEXICO HAS BETTER PAID
LEAVE.
POLICY THAT HOUSE THEY OFFER
TWELVE WEEKS.
BULGARIA ACCORDING TO MY
RESEARCH PROVIDES FORTY SIX
WEEKS.
AND OTHER COUNTRIES WITHOUT A
NATIONAL PARENTAL LEAVE.
I PAID POLICY INCLUDES FLY
DYLAN'S.
Là SOTO AND POP AND GETTING --
BUT I DO HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS
LAST YEAR.
NEW YORK TEACHERS IN NEW YORK
GOT SOME GOOD NEWS AS THEY
IMPLEMENTED A POLICY TO PROVIDE
SIX WEEKS.
OF FULLY PAID LEAVE FOR THEIR
TEACHERS.
WE CAN BE NEXT BY ROGER HAVE
OPEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS AND
SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WE'RE PROUD CO SPONSORS THIS
BILL BECAUSE THIS IS ULTIMATELY
AN ISSUE OF EQUITY.
THE MOTHER HAD PENALTY IS REAL
STUDIES SHOW THAT PAID MATERNITY
LEAVE REDUCES TURNOVER.
AND WOMEN ARE MORE LIKELY TO
RETURN TO WORK IF THEY HAVE THAT
HOWEVER A RECENT STUDY BY THE
BRIGHT HORIZONS FOUND THAT 41%
OF EMPLOYED AMERICANS PERCEIVE
WORKING MOMS AS LESS DEVOTED.
MORE THAN A THIRD JUDGE THEM FOR
NEEDING A FLEXIBLE SCHEDULE AND
THE NUMBER OF WOMEN WORRIED
ABOUT TELLING THEIR BOSSES ABOUT
PREGNANCY HAS GONE FROM 12% IN
TWO THOUSAND AND 14221% IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE MOTHER
HAD PENALTY EVEN FOLLOWS WOMEN
OF ALL THE WAY TO RETIREMENT THE
CASTERS DEFINED BENEFIT PROGRAM
ALLOWS WOMEN'S.
CLOTHES FOR THE CONVERSION OF
UNUSED SICK LEAVE INTO SERVICE
CREDITS AT RETIREMENT.
THIS MEANS THAT WOMEN WHO GIVE
BIRTH AND HAVE TO USE UP ALL OF
THEIR SICK LEAVE.
HAVE LESS WHEN THEY GO TO
RETIREMENT PUTTING THEM AT A
DISTINCT DISADVANTAGE TO MEN WHO
ALREADY DISPROPORTIONATELY
RETIRE WITH MORE SERVICE CREDITS
THAN WOMEN.
EVEN THOUGH THEY MAKE UP A
FRACTION OF THE TEACHING
POPULATION.
ULTIMATELY PAID MATERNITY LEAVE
AS AN EQUITY OF ISSUE THAT
IMPACTS THE ENTIRE FAMILY.
AND SHOULD REFLECT THE VALUES OF
OUR STATE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
RACHEL WALLACE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
AMY HI JAKE WITH THE UNIVERSITY
PROFESSIONAL AND TECHNICAL
EMPLOYEES THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA LOCAL NINETY
ONE NINETEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHELLE CAST OF THE SERVICE
EMPLACEMENTS ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
ALSO STRONG SUPPORT.
MAP BROAD FOR THE TEAMSTERS
UNITE HERE MACHINISTS LAW --
LONGSHOREMEN.
AND THE UTILITY WORKERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF
THE FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL COME ON
DOWN.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY GOOD
MORNING SERRA BY JUSTIN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS THERE'S A
HAND ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED WE
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
HER COMMITMENT TO FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN WE RECOGNIZE THE NEED
FOR FAMILY LEAVE TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE A WITH.
THE WELL BEING OF OUR FUTURE
STUDENTS AND HEALTH OF OUR
WORKFORCE AB FIVE HUNDRED SETS
UP A NEW BENEFIT WITHOUT ANY
STATE FUNDING OR SUPPORT TO A
COMEDY FULL PAY FOR EMPLOYEES ON
LEAVE. FOR A MINIMUM OF SIX
WEEKS WE DO NOT HAVE A CURRENT
SYSTEM BUILT INTO HER SCHOOL
BUDGETS TO RECOGNIZE THIS NEW
BENEFIT WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
ELLIE A STERN THREE TO RACK
LIMITED RESOURCES FROM STUDENT
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
THIS AT A TIME WHEN WE HAVE MUCH
PUBLIC ATTENTION ON CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT CAP AND INCREASING
RECRUITMENT IN THE FIELD OF
EDUCATION. TO OFFER AN
ALTERNATIVE THAT THE STATE
CONSIDER REQUIRING PARTICIPATION
STATE DISABILITY PROGRAM AS IT
IS AN EXISTING SERVICE AND
SYSTEM THAT WOULD REQUIRE LESS A
MINISTRY TO BURN AND TO MANAGE.
AB FIVE HUNDRED ALSO DOES NOT
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO ADDRESS
HOW LEDS WILL DELIVER
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES GIVEN THAT
WE WILL NEED TO THEIR HAND ON
LONG TERM SUBSTITUTES WHICH IS
IN HIGH DEMAND.
AT THIS TIME WITH PEEPS THE
LARGEST STAFFING SHORTAGE AT ALL
LEVELS FROM TEACHERS TO SCHOOL
BUS DRIVERS AND WE ASK THE STATE
INSTEAD TO CONSIDER BUILDING
UPON THE EXISTING CITY PROGRAM
THROUGH THE SD I PROGRAM.
INSTEAD OF CREATING A NEW
UNFUNDED SYSTEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS BAREBACK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION I JUST REALLY
WOULD LIKE TO APPRECIATE THAT
THE THE AUTHOR BREAKING THIS
BILL AS A HUSBAND TO A TEACHER --
TEACHER FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS
THAT TWO SMALL KIDS THOUGH
THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT SMALL
ANYMORE -- THIS WOULD HAVE
PROVIDED A BIG BENEFIT FOR US NO
DOUBT ABSOLUTELY WITH THAT I
DON'T DISAGREE WITH ANYTHING
THAT THE SPOKE SUPPORTERS HAVE
SAID.
OUR ISSUES AGAIN RELATED TO THE
FISCAL MATTERS -- THE PROPOSAL'S
NOT NECESSARILY A SOLUTION TO
THE PROBLEM BUT WHAT IT DOES IT
BRINGS THE CONVERSATION TO THE
TABLE WHICH IS NECESSARY.
NO DISAGREEMENT WITH THAT.
THE THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT THE
PROPOSAL DOESN'T PROVIDE THE
SOLUTION.
THE SOLUTION IS RATHER -- I'M
SORRY THE PROPOSAL SIMPLY JUST
ADDS TO MANY OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
EXISTING IN TERMS OF MANAGING
THEIR BUDGETS AND DEALING WITH
THE DEMANDS THAT THEY CURRENTLY
EXIST.
A SOLUTION PROVIDE THE FUNDING
SO SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN CONTINUE
TO FOCUS ON THE EXISTING
PROBLEMS THAT THEY FACE TODAY.
IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT WE HEARD
EARLIER AB -- THIRTY NINE THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
ACHIEVE JUST SIMPLY THE BASIC
SERVICES THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING.
FOR ABSENT FUNDING THE PROPOSAL
IS BEST LEFT TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE LABOR
PARTNERSHIP AND WHAT COURSE OF
ACTION TO ADDRESS THE SOPHIE'S
CHOICE DECISIONS THAT THEY NOT
MUST MAKE.
THE SCHOOLS ARE SEE FULL AND
FAIR FUNDING WHICH WE WERE ALL
ARGUING.
FOR AT ITS MOST LIKELY WE'RE NOT
EVEN HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
TODAY FRANKLY IT'S PROBABLY THE
THE WE ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE
PROBABLY CELEBRATING MANY THINGS
LIKE.
A SMALL CLASS SIZES COUNSELORS
RESOURCE SPECIALIST MORE FUNDING
FOR TEACHERS THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE PROUD
OF BUT THAT'S NOT WILL WORK
HAVING CONVERSATION TODAY ABOUT.
THE SCHOOLS RECEIVE THAT FUNDING --
INSTEAD WOULD BE SO I'M SORRY
UNTIL WE RECEIVE -- THAT LEVEL
OF FUNDING OR IF -- THIS BILL IS.
PROVIDES A SOLUTION WHICH
INCLUDES FUNDING -- WE MUST
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK
YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MICHAEL SIZER ON BEHALF OF THE
KERN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN THE FORTY SEVEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CURRENT
ALSO IN OPPOSITION REGRETFULLY.
MELANIE I CANNOT ON BEHALF OF
THE SCHOOLS ACCESS LIABILITY
FUND IN OPPOSE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
JEFF BOCK ON BEHALF OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATOR SET
BROWN BUT HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING OUT OF
ORDER WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WELCOME TO THE PARTY.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
APOLOGIZE TO ITS STILL ARE
STRAND FLOOR AS WITH CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU IS
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING MEN WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SENATOR PAN.
SENATOR TORONTO.
YEAH THANK YOU AND I KNOW STAFF
POSITIONS STEPPED AWAY BUT BUT
YEAH I GUESS.
IN MY MIND A AND AND STAND THAT
AND SCHOOLS THAT -- THAT
ACTUALLY.
IT'S THE TEACHERS.
WHO'D BE SEEN LEAVE WHO ARE ALSO
THE PRIMARY EFFECTUATE ERRORS I
MEAN THERE TO TO DIRECT I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S HOW WE EDUCATORS
[inaudible]
I AT THAT TRUE I MEAN THAT.
YES RIGHT OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THIS
IS SOS TO ME.
THIS BILL IS ALSO ABOUT THE
SHARING THAT THE WORK FORCE
SEISMIC TRACKING ADDITIONAL
WORKFORCE EXISTING WORKFORCE NOW
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION ABOUT YOUR OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE -- YOU KNOW
THE FUTURE SHINS I TEND TO SEE
OUT FAMILIES AFTER THEY HAVE
THEIR CHILDREN -- ME I THINK
THAT -- WE'VE SEEN A LOT THERE'S
A LOT OF DATA AND RESEARCH
SHOWING THE BENEFIT OF LEAVE FOR
THE CHILD BUT ALSO FOR THE
FAMILY OVERALL.
AND I THINK WE'RE TRYING.
TO SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE WHO
ACTUALLY HAS TO DO THE WORK OF
TEACHING OUR KIDS -- THIS WOULD
TO ME BE A GOOD IDEA SO I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES THAT.
YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT ON THE
FISCAL SIDE BUT ULTIMATELY.
PART OF WHAT WE'RE SPENDING THE
MONEY ON IS TO BE SURE THAT WE
CAN GET THAT KIND OF WORK FORCE
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
ACTUALLY PRODUCE THE RESULTS WE
WANT.
AND SUPPORTING THAT WORKFORCE TO
BE.
IN A WAY THAT -- WE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF RESEARCH SHOWED
THE BENEFIT WOULD MAKE SEEM TO
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE IT'S A
REASONABLE INVESTMENT OF EVEN
EXISTING DOLLARS WE CAN TALK WE
SHOULD WE CAN ALWAYS TALK.
DOLLARS BUT I'M NOT SURE WHAT WE
HAVE TO WAIT ESPECIALLY IN THE
BUDGET THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO PASS.
THE HAVE THE HIGHEST PER PUPIL
SPENDING WE SHOULD DO MORE FOR
NOT YOU KNOW COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES BUT STILL.
AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
OPPOSITION IS ABOUT.
THE USER PAN PLEASE PROCEED.
THEY ARE WATCHES THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION [inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT HASBRO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
TWO OF THE HANDOUT THAT WE
DISTRIBUTE IT WE WANTED TO LAY
OUT ALL THE BENEFITS THAT WE
CURRENTLY PROVIDE WHICH IS
HIGHLIGHTED ON OUR LETTER ABOUT.
THIS IS NOW AN ADDITIONAL NEW
BENEFIT PROP BEFORE WE UTILIZE
ALL THE SERVICE SAYS -- BEFORE
UP WE TAP INTO ALL THE OTHER
BENEFITS AND SO FOR US IT'S WE
COULD POTENTIALLY SEE EMPLOYEES
GOING FROM.
IF SOMEONE STEPS OUT IN
SEPTEMBER REALLY GOING ALL
THROUGH THE ACADEMIC YEAR
CURRENTLY AND SO THIS NEW
BENEFIT IS PROVIDED TO ANYONE BE
IT A NEW EMPLOYEE CERTIFICATE
ARE CLASSIFIED.
DOES NOT MATTER HOW MANY SIX
HOURS THEY HAVE BANKER VACATION
AND SO FOR US WE HAVE TO BE VERY
JUDICIOUS OF HOW DO WE ENSURE.
THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE NOT FACING
A SITUATION WHERE THEY HAVE LONG
TERM SUBSTITUTE FACT PRIOR FOR
ONE UNDER ALL SEE ABOUT.
THAT WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE THE BASIC SERVICES
THE CREDENTIALS STAFF AND THE
NECESSARY SUPPORT TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE.
UP PROVIDED AND SO FOR US WE
WANTED TO LAY OUT THAT WE
CURRENTLY UNDER THE SYSTEM
DECADES OF TWELVE SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES THEY DO BENEFIT HAVING
ALL OF THE SUPPORT.
IN ORDER TO PROPERLY TAKE THEIR
LEAVE AND THAT WE ALSO IN
ADDITION SCHOOL DISTRICTS
NEGOTIATE WITH EACH OF THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNITS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL BENEFITS AND
SO WHAT WE'RE RECOMMENDING IS
LOOK AT THE STATE DISABILITY
PROGRAM IT'S ALREADY IN
EXISTENCE.
LET'S NOT CREATE SOMETHING THAT
HAS NOT BEEN BILLED FOR FINANCE
SPORT SO THAT ADDITIONAL MINIMUM
SIX WEEKS THE YELLOW.
WE CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE ANY
MONEY.
FOR THE STARTING WHEN THIS BILL
TAKES EFFECT JANUARY FIRST WE
WOULD HAVE A DEFICIT IN OUR
BUDGETS BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT
ACCOUNTED FOR IT THANK YOU
CENTER PAN.
YEAH GET NOW JUST I GUESS TO ME
YET THE ALTERNATIVE IS YOU SAID
OKAY I UNDERSTAND CHALLENGE OF A
LONG TERM SUBSTITUTE AND PERHAPS.
ACTUALLY SHORTENS OF TO TRY MORE
OF AN ISSUE A LONG TERM --
ACTUALLY CONSEILS RELATIONSHIP
OF THE CLASS -- ME NO LONGER
REALLY TRULY BE A SUBSTITUTE IN
SOME SENSES BUT I THINK
ALTERNATIVE YOU'RE SAYING IS A
TEACHER WHO [inaudible]
TO HELD. TWO IS TRYING TO
BALANCE THAT CHILD TRYING TO
PROVIDE CARE FOR THAT CHILD.
INSTEAD WE'RE GONNA SAY IS THERE
TO ONCE YOU HAVE TO BE IN
CLASSROOM WHILE THEY'RE ALSO
WORRIED ABOUT HOW TO TAKE CARE
OF EVERYTHING ELSE I MEAN.
THAT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TELLING
ME THAT THAT'S A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE.
IT'S ACTUALLY JUST TO BE THERE
IT'S PREGNANCY THE NOT OCCUR
PREGNANCY LEAST RIGHT IT'S IN
SOME WAYS I MEAN IT DEPENDS HOW
YOU LOOK AT IT BUT IT'S EVEN I
THINK FROM A MEDICAL STANDPOINT.
MORE OFFENSIVE THAT YOU CAN'T --
TAKE A MEDICAL LEAVE WHEN YOU
HAVE A TOUGH PREGNANCY NOT
EVERYBODY TO I NEVER TO
PREGNANCY LEAVE I HAVE YOU KNOW --
AT C. SECTION AND ENDED UP
STARTING -- PAID FAMILY LEAVE
RIGHT AFTER BUT IT'S YOU KNOW
WHEN SOMEBODY IS BED BOUND WHEN
THEY HAVE A HOST OF
COMPLICATIONS -- THEY HAVE TO
USE UP ALL THEIR SICK TIME THEIR
VACATION TIME AND THE PAID
DEFERENTIAL BASICALLY PAY FOR
THEIR OWN SUBSTITUTE IN ORDER TO
TAKE THAT TIME TO HAVE A MEAN OF
COURSE SOME POINT THAT CAN BE
FOR RIGHT NOW I THINK WE'VE
HEARD SOME STORIES ABOUT THAT AS
WELL.
OKAY.
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO.
HELP MY GUESS SOMEONE OF THOSE
THAT'S SURPRISED.
SHOT.
ACTUALLY -- TO HEAR THAT THERE
IS NOT -- PAID.
OF PREGNANCY LEAVE THAT THAT'S
QUITE SURPRISING TO ME.
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS IS A
CONVERSATION FROM DECADES AGO --
THAT WAS TAKING PLACE I DON'T
TAKE LIGHTLY THE FISCAL ISSUES
AND AND AND CHALLENGES THAT.
ARE OUR SCHOOLS I HAVE TO GO
THROUGH TO BALANCE THINGS OUT
BUT THIS IS SOME THIS IS NOT A
LUXURY ITEM.
THIS IS A VERY BASIC OVER DO
ISSUE.
THAT [inaudible]
WOMEN.
WORK FOR THE OF THE DISTRICTS
SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT.
TO I ALSO SEE IS A PAY EQUITY
ISSUE.
UP TO SAY THAT.
WOMEN.
BECAUSE ONLY WOMEN WE'RE GONNA
GET PREGNANT -- IN WORD NARROWED
IT DOWN TO THAT -- WILL HAVE TO
GIVE UP THEIR VACATION AND SICK
LEAVE.
IS ANOTHER QUITE -- IF THE PAY
EQUITY ISSUE WE WILL NEVER HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE VACATION
WILL NEVER HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO USE HERE THERE WHATEVER YOU
MIGHT NEED FOR SICK LEAVE SO
[inaudible]
SOME [inaudible]
I AM.
I CAN'T.
IMAGINE NOT SUPPORTING THIS
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR TO RUSSELL ANY
OTHER CAUGHT QUESTION.
IT IS ALREADY BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR CHIANG AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
WOULD YOU KNOW AM I IT CARRY
THIS LAST YEAR WE'RE DOING IT
AGAIN AND I JUST RECENTLY.
LEARNED HOW WE'VE GOTTEN TO THIS
POSITION.
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE OF
COURSE KEYCHAIN AND AND EVEN
FACULTY MEMBERS WAS A LARGELY
WOMEN PROFESSION.
AND THE ORIGINAL FIGHT WAS
WHETHER OR NOT THEY COULD
CONTINUE TO TEACH WHEN THEY WERE
SHOWN AS PREGNANT.
I'M SO WHILE THEY WERE FIGHTING
THAT FIGHT WE WERE PROVIDING A
BASIS FOR OTHER WOMEN OUTSIDE
THAT PROFESSION TO GAIN OTHER
RIGHTS SO.
AN EQUAL KIND OF FIGHT MOVING
FORWARD -- AND THERE WAS A
BELIEF THAT YOU JUST SHOULD HAVE
YOUR BABY DURING THE SUMMER.
YOU KNOW -- WHEN A WOMAN IS
PREGNANT AND SHE HAS TO TAKE
SICK LEAVE BECAUSE PREGNANCY
LEAVE WHAT DOES THAT LEAVE HER
WHEN SHE HAS A NEWBORN?
RIGHT I MEAN THE REASON WE HAVE
SICK LEAVE IT IS SO THAT WE CAN
TAKE CARE OF NOT ONLY OURSELVES
BUT OUR CHILDREN YOU'RE PUTTING
THEM IN A POSITION THAT EVEN IF
WE SAID OKAY FINE.
WE'RE GOING TO JOIN THE SD I
PROGRAM WE'RE GONNA JOIN THE THE
PROGRAM THAT IS EIGHTY ONE POINT
1%.
PAYCHECK DEDUCTION FOR EVERY
TEACHER THAT ARE ACTUALLY
TELLING TEACHERS YOU NEED TO
TAKE -- EIGHT EIGHT PAY DECREASE
IN ORDER TO PART TO BE PART OF
THE SYSTEM THAT BY THE WAY IS
ONLY GOING TO PAY YOU 60% OF
YOUR SALARY YOU'RE STILL AT IT
AT A DEFICIT.
SO I THINK IN A A PROFESSION
THAT IS OVERWHELMINGLY WOMEN
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE NUMBER ONE REASON WOMEN
LEAVE THE TEACHING -- FIELD IT
HAS TO DO WITH FAMILY CHOICE
RIGHT.
IT ACTUALLY I WOULD ARGUE IN THE
LONG RUN IT'S GOING TO SAVE
SCHOOLS MONEY TO MAINTAIN THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR TEACHERS
AND HAVE THAT TEACHER COME BACK
AS AN EXPERIENCED TEACHER THAN
SAY ONCE I GET PREGNANT IT'S
JUST NOT WORTH IT TO CONTINUE IN
THIS FIELD.
SO WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT THE
TOTAL COST OF TO TOTAL COST TO
THE TO THE STUDENTS OF COURSE TO
THE TEACHERS TO THE PROFESSION
AND WE THE TOTAL VALUE OF THAT
WE PLACE ON TEACHERS I THINK WE
ALL I WOULD HOPE WE ALL BELIEVE
TEACHERS ARE UNDERPAID.
AND AND TO SUGGEST THAT THE
SOLUTION IS TO TAKE WAY MORE
THEIR SALARY I THINK IS IS SHORT
SIGHTED AND I THINK IT'S TIME TO
HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
INCOME REPLACEMENT MORE TALKING
ABOUT LEAVE WHETHER IT'S
PREGNANCY LEAVE OR WHAT WHETHER
IT'S PAID FAMILY LEAVE OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S SOMETHING I'M.
WORKING ON A DIFFERENT BILL BUT
YOU KNOW THIS IS PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION AND I THINK IT'S TIME
THAT WE WE START WITH TEACHERS
AND TEACHING PROFESSIONALS AND
AND AN ANCILLARY STAFF AT A
SCHOOL.
BOARD THAT AT LEAST THEY ARE
PROTECTED DURING PREGNANCY.
THANK YOU SIMPLY WOMAN THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR CHIANG
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM NINE AB FIVE HUNDRED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
AYE LEYVA AYE WILK WILK AYE
CHIANG CHIANG AYE LASSELL WHO
DOES SO I GLAZER REQUIRE PAN.
PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU.
THAT IS ITEM FIFTEEN A. B..
NINE FORTY THREE PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU CAN MORNING CENTER --
FOR SOME JUST TAKE A MOMENT AND
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT WITH
US ON THIS BILL -- THIS IS A
COMMITTEE THAT WELL KNOWS THE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS CENTERS
FACE IN OUR STUDENTS.
WHO ARE BARELY GETTING BY
WORKING MULTIPLE JOBS LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK WHILE THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS HELPED TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH
TUITION THE PRICE OF EDUCATION
GOES FAR BEYOND THAT? TO HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION AND BOOKS.
WE ALL KNOW THAT IF AN
UNFORESEEN FINANCIAL ISSUE COMES
UP A STUDENT GETS AFFECTED A
MEDICAL EMERGENCY A FAMILY
MEMBER PASSES AWAY.
THEY MAY BE.
OUT.
A SURVEY THIS YEAR FIFTY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FOUND THAT HALF OF ALL STUDENTS
ARE FOOD INSECURE. 60% OR
HOUSING AND SECURE ONE IN FIVE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS IN THE
PRIOR YEAR.
ANOTHER SURVEY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS FOUND ONE IN
FIVE UNABLE TO AFFORD EVEN ONE
MORE DOLLAR IN UNEXPECTED COSTS.
WHILE MOST STUDENTS WHO WITHDRAW
INTEND TO RETURN ONLY 38%
ACTUALLY DO SO AND WE NEED TO
HELP STUDENTS FROM WITH TRIED IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO ESTABLISH EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS AND
EMERGING PRACTICE. TO PROVIDE
STUDENTS A SHORT TERM RELIEF TO
HELP STAND ROLLED IN SCHOOLS.
A RECENT REVIEW OF EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FOUND THAT 95% OF STUDENTS
RECEIVED THIS AID FINISH THEIR
TERM. 80% WERE ENROLLED IN THE
NEXT SEMESTER THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW CAMPUSES TO USE EXISTING
FUNDS TO FUND SMALL GRANTS TO
STUDENTS AND FINANCIAL
EMERGENCIES.
OR AT RISK OF DROPPING OUT AND I
WOULD THINK THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE FACULTIES ACROSS THE
STATE STUDENTS AND OTHER
EDUCATION ADVOCATES FOR THEIR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WILL TURN
IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT PLEASE PROCEDURE TWO
MINUTES.
HELLO YES -- MY NAME IS DANNY
TERRIBLE I AM WITH THE STUDENTS
AND I FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS DIRECTOR
I THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME -- I
WON FIRST KNOWLEDGE THE GREAT
WORK THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS
DONE TO LOOK AT FINANCIAL AID
REFORM AND TO LOOK AT COVERING
THE TOTAL COST OF TUITION.
I'M YOU KNOW TEXT BOOKS
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING --
BUT THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY WOULD
GIVE STUDENTS.
ACCESS TO EMERGING REAL THE
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUNDS IN CASE
OF UNFORESEEN HARDSHIPS -- TO
PUT IN PERSPECTIVE FOR INSTANCE
THIS -- THIS YEAR WE'VE SEEN THE
BUTTE CAMPFIRE IT DISPLAYS A LOT
OF INDIVIDUALS STUDENTS CANNOT
GO TO CLASS -- AND WHEN NATURAL
DISASTERS LIKE THAT HAPPEN --
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE STILL
KEEP IN CONTACT WITH THE
STUDENTS TO GET THEM BACK AND
AFTER -- THIS IS THE RESULT --
BUT FINANCIAL AID IN ITSELF IS
NOT ENOUGH TO COVER AND PROVIDE
STABILITY FOR THAT STUDENT AND
SO GIVING THIS ESTABLISHING THIS
MARGINALLY RELIEF FUND -- WOULD
STABILITY -- ANOTHER EXAMPLE
LAST. TWO WEEKS AGO I WAS ABLE
TO HEAR TESTIMONY FROM A STUDENT
WHO DO WHO.
TALKED ABOUT HOW HER FATHER HAD
PASSED AWAY -- SOMEONE WHO
PROVIDE THE MAIN INCOME FOR THE
AND SO NOW THAT STUDENT IS IN A
CATCH TWENTY TWO OF TRYING.
TO SUPPORT HERSELF AND HER
FAMILY.
BUT CAN'T DO THAT UNLESS SHE HAS
AN EDUCATION.
AND SO WITH THIS BILL I WOULD
REALLY PROVIDE -- ASSISTANCE FOR
THE STUDENTS TO CONTINUE ON WITH
THEIR EDUCATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN WITH THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE'VE SEEN MULTIPLE SURVEYS COME
OUT OVER THE PAST YEAR SAID THAT
SHOWS ALMOST HALF OF OUR
STUDENTS FACE FOOD AND SECURITY --
AS WELL AS HOW IS IT HOUSING AND
SECURITY.
AB NINE FOUR THREE WOULD HELP
BATTLE THESE ISSUES BY ALLOWING
DISTRICTS TO USE STUDENT EQUITY
AND ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM FUND TO
PROVIDE THE STUDENTS WITH
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE.
THE PURPOSE OF THAT FUNDS NOT
PROGRAM IS TO HELP REFILL
CHANCES VISION THE FOR SUCCESS
BY ELIMINATING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
FOR STUDENTS FROM TRADITIONALLY
UNDER REPRESENTED GROUPS THOSE
ARE OFTEN THE STUDENTS OF THE
GREATEST FINANCIAL NEED. TO
ENSURE THIS POPULATION SUCCESSES
STUDENTS PHYSIOLOGICAL NEEDS
MUST BE MET THAT'S FOOD THAT'S
HOUSING.
AND EIGHTY NINE FOR THREE WOULD
ACTUALLY GIVE DISTRICTS THE
TOOLS TO HELP ASSIST THOSE
STUDENTS AND EMERGENCIES.
GOOD TWO MINUTES TO IT.
BUT SINCE SHE DIDN'T USE ALL
YOUR TIME YOU HAVE THIRTY
SECONDS.
THANK YOU BRIAN HOW THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE PROP CO SPONSORS
OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
I'M HERE TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
I UNDERGONE DRESS ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
THIS BEING A CHRISTOPOULOS
EMERSON WAS SCHOLARSHIP AMERICA
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NICK WRONGLY ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN ASSOCIATION FOR COLLEGE
ADMISSION COUNSELING AND SUPPORT.
IN MARIN MAJID ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE JUST
CHANCE OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SHOULD ASK PRECIADO -- THE
CONSIDERATION AS FOR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE FORTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WELL WILK AYE CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D WRESTLE WITH A
SLIGHTLY.
MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
THANK YOU SIMILARLY THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO
ADD ON MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING
TO DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM TWO AB THIRTY ITEM TEN AB
SIX TWELVE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
EIGHT OH SIX ITEM SEVENTEEN AB.
FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
ITEM NINETEEN AB.
SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO CONSENT AS
AMENDED ITEM ELEVEN AB SEVEN OH
NINE ITEM SIXTEEN A. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY THREE WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO
RETHINK FROM CONSENT.
SIGNALED THE BILL HAD THE
CONSENT CALORIES BUT MOVE BY
SENATOR PAN AND SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILK.
WILK I CHANGE CHIANG I'D RUSSELL
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN ADOPTED.
THANK YOU EVERYONE VERY MUCH AS
ANYONE NEED TO ADD ON I THINK A
CENTER PAN AND CENTER CHIANG
ALRIGHT WE ARE GOING TO START.
CALLING THE ROLE ON OPEN BILLS.
OKAY RESERVE AND FIVE SANTIAGO
AB THREE FIFTY SIX PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM FIVE EIGHTY THREE FIFTY SIX
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
FLOOR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE
I SURE VOTING I FOUR ZERO THAT --
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
CAN I CAN I HOLD THAT WILL OPEN
FOR SENATOR MCGUIRE NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM FOURTEEN SANTIAGO AB EIGHT
OH NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT OR
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
FOUR ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
WE WILL HOLD UP TO OPEN AS WELL.
NEXT BILL IS.
ITEM SIX SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEBER AB THREE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM SIX AB THREE SIXTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
THREE ZERO CHIANG.
A GLAZER.
GLAZER NO MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
BELIEVE THAT BILL OPEN AS WELL
[inaudible]
FILE ITEM.
YES FILE ITEM SEVEN MEDINA AB
FOR TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM SEVEN AB.
FOR TWENTY EIGHT IT PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FOUR
ZERO CHANGE.
CHIANG I'D GLAZER PLEASE ARE AYE
MCGUIRE.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN AS WELL.
AND SHE IT WAS PULLED.
YES TWO BILLS REPORTS.
WE WILL START WITH FILE ITEM ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU A. B. EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM ONE AB EIGHT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO HELP WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FIVE
ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
LEAVE THAT OPEN AS WELL.
FILE ITEM THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI A. B..
THIRTY NINE ITEM THREE AB THIRTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE LEAVE THAT
OPEN AS WELL.
ITEM FOUR AB.
THREE FIFTY FOUR WITH THEM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I AM BY SURE VOTING I
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
.
OKAY ITEM NINE AB FIVE HUNDRED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE FRAZIER VOTING I FIVE
ZERO GLAZER [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
IN ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT OR
NINE THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
I AM FIFTEEN A. B. NINE FORTY
THREE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING AYE.
FIVE ZERO GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE.
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATORS WE ARE WAITING FOR
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
COME ON DOWN CENTER MCGUIRE
IT'S
FREEZING I DON'T SMOKE BARBECUE
THOUGH -- WELCOME SENATOR
MCGUIRE THANK YOU FOR COMING
FROM YOUR COMMITTEE WE
APPRECIATE YOU WE ARE NOW GOING --
TO CALL THE ROLL ON THE OPEN
ITEMS.
ITEM ONE AB EIGHT THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO HELP WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THAT'S HELPED.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM THREE AB.
THIRTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ADVISED HER
VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE NINE THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM FOUR AB THREE
FIFTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM FIVE AB THREE
FIFTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE FOR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I ADVISED HER VOTING I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM SIX AB THREE SIXTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FOUR
ZERO CHIANG.
MCGUIRE INQUIRE AYE THE BILL IS
OUT. SEVEN AB FOR TWENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM NINE AB FIVE
HUNDRED THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE VICE CHAIR VOTING I
GLAZER MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE [inaudible]
THOSE OUT. SIX SIX ZERO ITEM
FOURTEEN AB EIGHT ZERO EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THE BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM FIFTEEN EIGHTY
NINE FORTY THREE THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE AYE
STERN VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO IN ORDER TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSENT
CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT AS WELL
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU EVERYONE WE STAND
ADJOURNED IN SAN EDUCATION